Guten Morgen Markus. Morgen Tim. Was hast du mit Linus gemacht.
Guten Morgen Tim. Äh ich habe ihnen gegen Matthias ausgetauscht.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer einhundertzweiundneunzig und äh ihr hört es schon. Heute mit ohne Linus, weil der ist äh mal wieder tja, wer weiß das schon so genau.
Irgendwo ist er, aber äh wir wollen ja hier unsere Kronisten und Berichtspflicht auch weiterhin nachkommen und deswegen haben wir uns heute mal eine spezielle äh Illustro äh Runde zusammengestellt und.
Habt schon gehört. Markus und Matthias sind da. Hallo Markus.
Hallo.
Mannes Reuter, Matthias Monreu und ihr seid beide äh unter anderem Autoren für Netzpolitik Punkt org. Ähm wie lange schreibst du schon Markus?
Ich bin seit März zweitausendsechzehn dabei.
Ja, aber das Thema ist ja sozusagen ja nicht äh fremd, sondern jetzt schon immer so zum Satellitensystem von Netzpolitik Org in der einen oder anderen Form, kann man so sagen, oder?
Kann man so sagen, also Bürgerrechte, Grund- und Freiheitsrechte sind für mich seit Jahren ein Thema und.
Aber ist ja auch interessant, dass also Netzpolitik Org, ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das jetzt alles so im Nachgang des äh Landesverrats, dass die Redaktion doch schon signifikant aufgestockt wurde.
Ja, die ist deutlich größer geworden, äh so groß, dass wir dann irgendwann die Räume wechseln mussten, also äh weil wir auf zwanzig Quadratmetern zu zwölf saßen mit Praktikanten. Äh genau und sind jetzt, glaube ich, sechseinhalb volle Stellen oder so.
Wow, das ist schon ganz ordentlich, finde ich. Volle Stellen und dann aber auch nochmal so diverse sonstige äh Zuträger.
Ja, sechseinhalb volle Stellen insgesamt, ne? Also das gibt Leute, die machen nur eine halbe oder dreiviertel Stelle und dann gibt's meistens noch zwei, drei Praktikantinnen und Praktikanten. Also so um die zehn Leute sind da schon immer am Start über die Woche, wenn nicht mehr sogar.
Ein richtiges Gewusel,
Ja, das finde ich äh finde ich eigentlich sehr schön, dass so ein so ein Projekt, ich meine Blog, wir wissen ja alle, wie das so ist, ne? Sich äh quasi so als Alternativmedium im Netz zu behaupten
ist nicht einfach und das scheint aber derzeit ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Ja, funktioniert gut. Ich meine, das Schöne ist ja daran, dass das Ganze komplett äh äh Laserfinanziert ist, ne? Also es
der quasi keine großartige Werbung, die da geschaltet wird, einfach weil wir das Tracking nicht wollen und äh das funktioniert ganz gut, ist natürlich immer auf Spenden angewiesen und
Mache jetzt nicht die Werbetour hey, ihr könnt doch spenden, aber klar, so ein Dauerauftrag hier Luft.
Nee, das ist nicht echt schön, weil du auch nur den Leserinnen und Lesern verpflichtet bist, ne.
Und du Matthias, du schreibst auch schon öfter ab und zu mal, wenn ich das richtig deute, ne, auf.
Ja, seit ein paar Jahren inzwischen.
Und was ist so dein Hintergrund.
Namen Background ist eigentlich eher aus dem Bereich von äh linken Aktivismus, habe mich dann vor na ja gut zehn Jahren ein bisschen fokussiert auf die äh internationale Zusammenarbeit von Polizei
Überwachung, bin dann so ein bisschen bei der Europäischen Union hängengeblieben und macht das,
ja seit ungefähr zehn Jahren, dass ich dann auch äh darüber geschrieben habe, teilweise unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte. Ich mache viel zu Europol, europäischen Polizeidatenbanken, aber auch so
Vorbereitung für irgendwelche große Ereignisse, Gipfelproteste, wieder Daten getauscht werden, wie die Polizei zusammenarbeitet. So ein bisschen, dann habe ich noch ein paar Spezialthemen, also seit
vielen Jahren arbeite ich auch zu Drohnen, kleinen, großen, mittleren von Polizei, von Militär, diese Entwicklung habe ich so ein bisschen begleitet,
Ja und ansonsten wissen dies und das.
Dein Twitter-Account ist Gipfelsoli, gibt's da irgendwie eine bestimmte Story dazu.
Wegen der Gipfelproteste. So kam ich dazu, also ich hab
ähm immer wieder mich mit so Antirepressionsstrukturen bei Gipfelprotesten äh beschäftigt. Das erste war zweitausendeins in Genua, so bin ich quasi auch äh sage ich mal zum Thema gekommen, weil ich da auch äh Nebenkläger
gegen die Polizei gewesen bin. Es gab da,
wer sich da noch dran erinnert, äh, massive Repressionen seitens der Polizei, es wurde grade Giani erschossen, es wurden Razzien gemacht in Schlafstätten von Demonstrantinnen und Demonstranten, Leute waren teilweise wochenlang im Knast,
Und das habe ich dann immer wieder gemacht bei folgenden Gipfeln und so kam eben diese Gipfelsolidarität eine Webseite, wo ich auch mitgemacht habe.
So ein Projekt und das ist quasi noch übrig geblieben davon.
Die Proteste in Genual das war ja im Prinzip so wie nicht so der Urknall, ne? Der des sichtbaren und spürbaren Widerstands bei EU-Gipfeln. Bis dahin waren das immer so Altherrenrunden.
G acht Gipfel war das in dem Fall.
Die EU-Gipfel haben sie dann eingedampft zu Hinterzimmergesprächen, die waren früher eigentlich auch relativ groß inszeniert. Also wenige Wochen vorher, zweitausendeins war der EU-Gipfel in Goetheburg
Auch da kam's zu massiven Protesten. Äh da hat die Polizei auch geschossen übrigens. Mehrmals äh sogar. Da
äh nur durch Glück, nichts Schlimmeres passiert, aber auch da saßen Leute dann wochenlang im Knast und dann gab's tatsächlich diese äh internationale Amtshilfe, die schwedische Polizei hat dann das LKA Berlin äh,
geheißen, hier Durchsuchungen zu machen, beispielsweise oder auch in Genua ist das so gewesen, dass vor dem Gipfel dann
die italienische Polizei Daten aus Deutschland bekommen hat äh von mutmaßlichen Störern. Es gab dann Ausreiseverbote auch, also
damalige Innensenator Berlins hat das dann gerechtfertigt, dass also Deutsche eben nicht ins Ausland zum Protestieren reisen durften mit dem Ding, äh, mit der Begründung, es gäbe in Deutschland kein Grundrecht auf Ausreise.
Das war der äh Erd Körting war das äh damals SPD.
Das war zwölf Jahre nach dem äh Fall der Mauer, wo ein Berliner Innensenator sagt, es gibt in Deutschland kein Grundrecht auf Ausreise, fand ich äh
Damals doch schon recht spektakulär und ich sage mal über diese Themen bin ich dann äh eigentlich so auf diese Europäische Union und wie funktioniert eigentlich diese ganze Datentauschgeschichte? Was passiert da so im Hintergrund? Und
Es haben sich relativ wenig Leute mit diesen ganzen EU-Themen beschäftigt. Äh das ist heute ein bisschen anders im digitalen Bereich gibt's das. Aber ansonsten, ich sage mal, im aktivistischen Bereich,
ist das schon sehr mau, also gibt es sehr wenig Bewegung, würde ich mal sagen und auch Auseinandersetzung mit den Themen.
Ja. Deswegen haben wir dich hier heute auch äh eingeladen, weil wir gleich nochmal äh etwas ausführlicher auf diese ganze
ähm Situationen von Überwachungs und Datenbanksystemen auf EU-Ebene zu sprechen kommen wollen, ausgehend auf den äh von den Meldungen, die wir
letzte Woche hier bei Lok Buchnetz Politik ja auch schon angesprochen haben
also vor allem diese sogenannte Berliner Erklärung zur inneren äh Sicherheit und dann äh auch noch dieses Eckpunktepapier, was dann zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich ja äh ins Gespräch kam, wo es ähm ja
wo man sich so ein bisschen wunderte, dass eine gemeinsame Erklärung irgendwie im wesentlichen Ost zwei sehr unterschiedlichen Darstellungen ähm ähm bestand.
Ähm bis wir eigentlich Matthias bist du ein ähm
Verstehst du nicht, um mich als Journalist oder was ist so deine eigentliche Verordnung? Weil das nimmt ja relativ viel Zeit ein, nehme ich mal an, ne, so eine Aktivität.
Ja, ich schreibe inzwischen sehr viel, Journalist würde ich mich jetzt nicht unbedingt nennen äh ähm
Ich äh manchmal sage ich Wissensarbeiter, weil es mir einfach äh also ich habe inzwischen Teilzeitjob auch für einen Abgeordneten Bundestag, das gibt mir halt die Möglichkeit äh sehr viel ähm Informationen zu sammeln und was ich bei Netzpolitik mache, ist dann einfach äh zu versuchen, diese Sachen so ein bisschen einzudampfen
und zu beschreiben, aufzuschreiben.
Mhm. Habe ja gelernt, man soll man soll ja nicht ähm abstreiten, Journalist zu sein, weil das könnte ja bestimmt nochmal ganz hilfreich sein.
Finde auch, also sehe ich auch kein Problem an äh an der Kombination quasi von Journalismus und Aktivismus, wenn dann die Information, die man aufschreibt,
eben Fakten basiert und Faktentreu ist. Ich glaub das ist das Wichtigste, dass das eine Subjektivität und eine eigene Haltung gibt, das ist eh klar und das hat
mich persönlich schon immer genervt an an Medien, die so dieses Objektive wie so eine Monstranz vor sich halten, weil es gibt keine Objektivität, aber es gibt halt Fakten, die überprüfbar sind und Dinge, die gesagt wurden und ich glaube, das ist das Wichtige, also ich würde mich schon als Journalist bezeichnen.
Gut kommen wir mal ähm so ein bisschen ins Themenfeld bevor wir auf unser Hauptthema äh kommen, sollten wir vielleicht noch ein, zwei äh Nachrichten kurz äh
erwähnen
auch wenn ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher bin, wie viel wir da jetzt wirklich ähm zu sagen können. Zunächst einmal ging's ein wenig weiter in der äh Saga,
äh des äh NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses. Ähm wir erinnern uns seit
Anfang an eigentlich seit seit äh dem dieser Untersuchungsausschuss an Start gekommen ist, gab's die Forderung etwas Noten als Zeugen einzuladen,
es gab auch ja diverse Beschlüsse das dann doch mal vielleicht auch tun zu wollen, so es sich denn so ergibt und seitdem ergeben sich vor allem immer sehr viele ähm,
Gründe das nicht zu tun, weil das wäre ja alles so schwierig. Man muss ja irgendwie ganz viel prüfen und man muss ja irgendwie dann nochmal,
und dann müssen wir nochmal nachschauen und überlegen und politische Abwägung machen und Pipapo, also so ein Eiertanz, der die ganze Zeit vor sich.
Hin ruppelt und ähm ja, das äh hat man ja hier auch schon immer mal wieder erwähnt.
Tatsache ist, es ist bis heute nicht dazu gekommen.
Der eingeflogen wird. Man kann sich natürlich auch vorstellen, warum sich die Bundesregierung da äh sehr windet, weil sie einfach ja Schiss haben, sich äh mit den USA da äh quer zu legen, weil der
politische Widerstand dürfte an der Stelle ja doch sehr stark sein. Die Opposition.
Ist davon allerdings nicht sonderlich begeistert und äh versucht es jetzt, wo er dieser Untersuchungsausschuss im Prinzip in sein letztes Jahr geht. Probiert es jetzt nochmal mit einer neuen äh Keule, wobei die.
Ja, die Waffenausstattung.
Besonders für die schwache Opposition im Bundestag ja nicht besonders stark ist und ist jetzt vorgegangen, äh, indem sie ein ja.
Ein Antrag gestellt hat, wie es da heißt äh beim Bundesgerichtshof, um sozusagen die,
die Rechte des Untersuchungsausschusses dahingehend zu wahren, dass sie ja im Prinzip die Freiheit haben sollte, eben diese Zeugen zu benennen und dann eben auch einzuladen im Sinne der Aufklärung. Wir hatten vorhin schon so ein bisschen gerätselt.
Was ist denn sozusagen da konkret mit auf sich hat, also welche juristische Stellung das Ganze hat? Beklage, also ist ein bisschen unklar, es wird von von Klägern jetzt gesprochen.
Aber so eine richtige Klage in dem Sinne scheint mir das jetzt auch nicht zu sein, sondern mehr so eine Aufforderung zur Rechtsermahnung an den Bundesgerichtshof im Bezugnahme auf das äh Untersuchungsausschussgesetz.
Klingt ein bisschen hilflos, oder?
Na, ich weiß nicht, ich meine, es wurde ja irgendwie in äh in anderen Medien äh als äh ein offener Brief äh stilisiert. Das ist nämlich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist schon sehr eine offizielle Art und Weise vorzugehen. Ich glaube, dass die Opposition einfach
alles ausschöpft, was geht und alle Versuche macht und das ist halt der weitere Versuch in dieser mittlerweile mehr als zwei Jahre lang Serie von Versuchensnoten herzubekommen
Hintergrund ist natürlich, dass äh die äh die Koalition will ihn quasi in Moskau oder per Video befragen
und er selber lehnt das aber auch ab.
Nachvollziehbar, nachvollziehbar. Was da sein, dein Tipp, wird's dazu nochmal kommen.
Ich kann mir schwer vorstellen, dass Snowden nach Berlin dort aussagt. Obwohl es natürlich für diesen Untersuchungsausschuss wichtig und richtig wäre, wenn das passiert.
Ja. Also die Grünen und Linken die sind halt sozusagen die einzigen, die dahinter stehen, kennen das Spiel schon äh,
nicht, also Untersuchungsausschuss hat ja immer dieselben Mehrheitsverhältnisse wie eben der Bundestag und die kennen wir ja nun, die sind da einfach nicht gerade besonders Oppositionsfreundlich gestaltet.
Müssen wir sehen, was dabei herauskommt.
Ja, so ein bisschen auf äh unser Thema, unser eigentliches Thema hinleiten, gab's da noch die Meldung ähm dass,
WhatsApp, also der ja sehr erfolgreiche Messenging Messagingdienst
der ähm unlängst von Facebook einverleibt wurde für teuer Geld, ähm jetzt auch wohl bereit ist oder es auch schon bereits tut, Daten, die im Rahmen des Betriebes von Whats.
Anfallen, auch mit Facebook zu teilen. Ich glaube, da ist jetzt auch keiner so richtig überrascht.
Na ja, das ist interessant ist dabei, dass dieser Kauf war äh von durch Facebook hieß es ja, es wird sich nichts ändern und was sie jetzt machen, ist halt vor allem sich an dieser Telefonnummernweitergabe äh äh,
also das zu machen und da muss man zu sagen, dass die Telefonnummer halt ein,
sogenannter Universal Identifire ist, also Menschen haben mehrere Mail-Adressen, sie haben äh sind aber eine Telefonnummer tauscht man nicht so häufig, das heißt, ich kann
an der Telefonnummer sehr gut Menschen über Geräte und Netzwerke hinweg erkennen. Und das ist eigentlich der Hintergrund, glaube ich, warum
Facebook das auf jeden Fall machen will und jetzt diese teure Kuh melden will ähm weil.
Was dann eben passiert, ich habe dann diese diese WhatsApp-User und jetzt werden die Telefonnummern weitergegeben und ich kann als Werbetreibender quasi sagen, okay, ich habe hier mein,
Datensatz von Telefonnummern schmeißt den bei Facebook rein und dann kann ich quasi diesen diesen WhatsApp Usern äh Nachrichten schreiben oder Werbung schalten oder so, ne? Also das ist äh,
schon ziemlich wertvolle Sache, wenn man Telefonnummern hat. Ähm und jetzt ging die Sache so weiter, dass dann WhatsApp natürlich, also das Interessante ist ja, WhatsApp hat sich
quasi in den letzten zwei Jahren durch diese Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, die ja was kann äh eigentlich so ein bisschen so freigespielt von diesem Facebook-Deal äh und hat viele User gewonnen und eine gewisse Glaubwürdigkeit wieder erlangt. Äh,
und jetzt verliert sie es halt wieder. Äh.
Und ähm was WhatsApp jetzt macht ist, ihr könnt dem widersprechen und dann haben sie so eine Seite, die man aber auch nicht ganz einfach findet äh
aufgesetzt und da kann ich den Widerspruch machen, aber dieser Widerspruch ist so überspezifisch äh formuliert. Das heißt, ich kann eigentlich nicht dieser
widersprechen, also nicht dieser Telefondaten äh Telefonnummernweitergabe, sondern nur dieser gezielten Werbung, was dann Facebook damit macht
das ist natürlich echt ein Quatsch und man kann Leuten wirklich nur empfehlen andere Messenger zu nutzen, es gibt Alternativen,
verschiedenster Art. Da kann man durch eine riesen Diskussion führen,
Ich habe in dem in der Sache immer äh zwei empfohlen, das einerseits äh Freemar, das aber nicht äh offen, kein offener Quellcode, andererseits muss ich da keine Telefonnummer angeben. Und die andere Sache wäre Signal äh,
Da muss man.
Telefonnummer aber auch eine Rolle spielt.
Da muss ich die Telefonnummer auch angeben, aber ist eben Open Source und hat eine sehr gute Verschlüsselung und,
Ich persönlich finde halt wichtig bei so einer Sache bei einem wie WhatsApp, wo eine Milliarde Menschen irgendwie kommunizieren, kann ich nicht eben,
komplizierte Lösungen empfehlen, wenn irgendwie,
Leute die mit Computern oder eben nicht so gut umgehen können wechseln sollen, deswegen muss man da Kompromisse eingehen. Es gibt sicher noch zig andere Varianten
aber das waren so die, also jetzt ist ein guter Zeitpunkt zu wechseln und nicht diesen Pseudowiderspruch zu machen, sondern sich gleich ganz abzumelden und eben.
Da gab's dann immer viele Leute, die gesagt haben, ja, aber das bringt so nichts und alle meine Freunde sind bei WhatsApp und da können doch eh nicht wechseln, aber irgendwer muss glaube ich den Anfang machen und wenn man kein WhatsApp mehr hat, dann werden die Leute schon
Per anderem Messenger einen kontaktieren, also das äh kann schon passieren.
Na ja, da bist du sehr optimistisch. Muss er dazu sehen.
Die Sache mit der Telefonnummer war ja im Prinzip so ein Geniestreich. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob WhatsApp die ersten waren, aber ich glaube, sie waren schon diejenigen, die darüber auch am meisten Welle erzeugt haben, weil was ja immer dieses Problem
eben in so einem Kommunikationsnetz äh wirklich einen Nutzen davon haben willst, dann
muss so eben, brauchst du irgendwie am Marcel, muss vor allem auch irgendwie leicht deine Freunde finden. Und diese Methode, einfach die Telefonnummer quasi als Schlüssel zu nehmen und,
da ja alle Leute quasi viele Telefonnummern bereits in ihrem Adressbuch äh drin hatten und man in dem Moment, wo man der App halt erlaubt
diese Nummern auszulesen, dann eben sehr schnell ein Matching machen kann, okay, wen kennen wir denn von den Leuten, die du meinst zu kennen? Äh hatte man dann eben mit einem einmal ja sagen oder ich glaube am Anfang noch nicht mal mit ja sagen
quasi automatisch alle Leute, die man ohnehin mehr oder weniger öfter äh anruft oder zumindest mal die Telefonnummer notiert hat, dann eben auch gleich über WhatsApp erreichbar.
Das war natürlich das, was so ein bisschen Durchbruch gemacht hat und deswegen haben das auch alle eigentlich kopiert. Mit der Ausnahme von Srima und Hocker und.
Also Freemer kann man das auch machen, ne? Also du kannst bei der Free mal auch deine Telefonnummer oder per E-Mail als Identifier das machen, das funktioniert auch, also du machst dabei auch Datenaustausch und hast halt wieder nicht das. Ich bin da irgendwie komplett äh anonym unterwegs oder.
Genau, da weiß man nicht so ganz genau, wie die Software dann halt damit umgeht, was äh was ja sagen wir mal, eine verhältnismäßig akzeptable
Methode ist es, dass man die Telefonnummern nimmt, aber nicht als solche quasi an den Server weitergibt, der dann das Matching vornimmt, sondern dass man eben quasi nur so ein Hash bildet, also nur so ein kryptografische Kurzzusammenfassung
der Telefonnummer und darüber vergleicht, sodass
dann zwar Daten verglichen werden, aber eben nicht die eigentliche Telefonnummer direkt ersichtlich ist. Ähm gut, jetzt eine Telefonnummer auch nicht so mega lang, also das,
ist auch nicht so ganz klar, ob man nicht aus diesen Daten in Zweifelsfall auch wiederum ganz gut zurückverfolgen könnte, was denn nun die Telefonnummer vielleicht dahinter gewesen sein möge
aber ähm man muss schon unterscheiden zwischen Messengern, die eben einfach sagen, ja okay, das ist jetzt hier unser Key, sodass die sagen
Nee, du musst, um mit jemandem kommunizieren zu können, in irgendeiner Form erstmals.
Zugang haben zu diesem eigentlichen Key, den wir hier als Identifikation verwenden und der eben spezifisch für diese Anwendung ist. Das macht's natürlich dann auch gleich wieder,
komplizierter und umständlicher, das sieht man bei solchen Sachen wie Frima, weil man eigentlich sein Netzwerk nur dadurch gut aufbauen kann, indem man die Leute wirklich mal trifft und dann.
QR kurz abscannen und so weiter, was natürlich auch so ein kleiner Nerdporn ist so, aber ist es vollkommen klar,
darüber kann man eben die Massen nicht so ohne Weiteres erreichen. Frima hat dann gleich auf seinem Blog äh gejubelt, was er dann doch wieder jetzt für gesteigerte Downloadraten äh hätten nach dem WhatsApp das so bekanntgegeben hat oder diese Information.
Veröffentlicht wurde, inwiefern das eben dauerhaft äh hält und hilft äh ist er nochmal eine ganz andere Diskussion.
Was man aber hier jetzt schön sehen kann ist, dass eigentlich in dieser ganzen Diskussion um verschlüsselte Kommunikation nochmal so eine.
Neue Ebene dazu kommen, die bisher eigentlich relativ wenig Aufmerksamkeit erhalten hatte
Ganz zu Anfang ist ja WhatsApp auch komplett unverschlüsselt unterwegs gewesen, also die haben sich eigentlich nur darum gekümmert, ihre Nachrichten schnell durch die Gegend gefeuert zu bekommen und das konnten sie irgendwie sehr gut und darüber waren sie schon erfolgreich.
Dann war dann irgendwann der Druck zu stark, dass man gesagt hat, also hier komplett Unverschlüsse geht's noch, irgendwie,
Jetzt das einundzwanzigste Jahrhundert, hast du schon erwähnt, das haben sie dann relativ gut nachgerüstet, haben sich da äh.
Glaube ich im Wesentlichen dieselbe Technologie zugelegt, die auch bei Single zum Einsatz kommt. Nur das wäre mit wem.
Ding, also der, der die Meterdaten, der Kommunikation, die wir jetzt auch im Rahmen der ganzen Snowden-Debatten und äh Thematiken auch im Untersuchungsausschuss immer wieder gehabt haben.
Die liegen halt trotzdem vor, beziehungsweise ist nicht so hundertprozentig klar.
Was für Datenbestände jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich dort vorliegen oder eben auch inwiefern diese Unternehmen auch selber da auf Vorrat speichern. Bei WhatsApp wissen wir es einfach nicht.
Gut, das sind,
sehr, sehr, sehr viele Nachrichten, die da äh rübergehen, keine Ahnung, wie viel Milliarden Nachrichten, die schon äh so pro Tag durch die Gegend feuern. Es sind bestimmt eine ganze Menge.
Bei einer Milliarde User dürfte da was zusa.
Da dürfte einiges zusammenkommen und ähm WhatsApp ist ja auch nicht, sagen wir mal die einzige App, die da äh global relevant ist, Laien und äh ich will das jedes Mal Chat und so weiter sind ja auch alles sehr populäre Systeme, wenn auch nicht so im westlichen westlichen Helm ist
fähre, sondern dann eben mehr in Asien und China vor allem in Japan
Ja und ähm man kann nur darüber munkeln wie Vorratsdatenspeicher freundlich diese Mieterdaten dort gehandhabt werden. Aber es ist natürlich durchaus vorstellbar
dass dieses Ganze, wer mit wem, Ding eben auch mit äh gespeichert wird und dann sind wir halt auch wieder bei den Begehrlichkeiten angekommen.
Ja und ja, genau bei diesen Begehrlichkeiten sind wir jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen bei unserem.
Kernthema angekommen. Hat's ja schon vorhin angedeutet, letztes äh letzte Woche kamen halt diese Berliner Erklärung äh heraus.
De Maisier halt gesagt hat na ja nicht wahr? Es kann ja nicht sein, dass klassische Formulierungen.
Äh und auch dort war WhatsApp dann auch ein Thema und diese Begehrlichkeiten nach Mieterdaten sind offen zu Tage getreten.
Danach kam halt dann dieses Eckpunktepapier zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich im Rahmen der äh Terrormaßnahmen auf den Tisch und äh
man merkte, dass einfach da eine gewisse Gier nach äh Überwachung von etwas, was sie derzeit nicht so recht überwacht bekommen. Ähm da ist,
weil de facto sind einfach die Messenger jetzt so die die Herren der Kommunikation, ja? Äh man hat jetzt.
Systeme, die mega populär sind und all die ganzen Möglichkeiten auf Telefonate zurückzugreifen, indem man einfach.
Den meist ja immer noch
sehr national aufgehängten Telekommunikationsunternehmen nachfragt oder dort vielleicht auch installierte Systeme zum Einsatz bringt, SMS war lange Zeit eben quasi so der Messenger der universell,
weltweit zum Einsatz kamen, einfachen Standards genügte, selbst wenig,
Verschlüsselung vorhielt, also bestenfalls die Wegstrecke über die Luft und da wissen wir ja auch, dass das alles mittlerweile mehrfach äh geknackt ist.
Also äh diese ganzen Zugriffe,
die sie haben, sind jetzt eigentlich in gewisser Hinsicht nichts mehr wert, da dort nur noch ein ähm ja wahrscheinlich eine Minderheit der Kommunikation stattfindet und der Großteil geht eben jetzt auf diese ganzen privaten Anbieter, die,
einfach groß werden konnten, indem sie sich einfach auf Smartphones als App äh eingenistet haben.
Und da stehen wir jetzt, jetzt haben wir im Prinzip genauso diese Wunschlage, dass doch mal wieder diese Überwachungshoheit wiederhergestellt wird, eben auch im Hinblick auf die ganzen privaten Messenger und da gibt's einige abzuholen.
Ne, so habe ich das jetzt erstmal äh.
Vielleicht noch äh zu der Zusage äh Überwachungsoffensive quasi, also es gab drei Schritte. Äh das eine war
eben dass die Erklärung von Demizier selbst, also BMI, Bundesministerium ist innen
Am elften August und dann kam eine Woche später, am neunzehnten, kamen die Berliner Erklärung, das sind alle CDU-Innenminister der Länder plus Demizier.
Was noch schärfer ist so und kurz danach kommt dann diese deutsch-französische Erklärung und im Hinblick jetzt auf diese,
Auf diese Messenger gibt's in jeder dieser Forderungskataloge ist die Forderung drin eben die äh.
Das wird dort genannt Telemediendienste, die zur Kommunikation genannt werden, also muss sich unterscheiden, es gibt Telekommunikationsdienste, das ist sowas wie mein Internetanschluss, Telefonanschluss und es gibt eben Telemediendienste, was quasi das ganze Internet ist, so magrob
gesagt, ne? Und jetzt hat Demizial gesagt, ja, wir müssen alle Telemediendienste, die zur Kommunikation geeignet sind.
Zu Telekommunikationsdiensten, also den rechtlich gleichstellen. Das heißt, Telekommunikationsdienste müssen werden einerseits irgendwie kann man da Telekommunikationsüberwachung machen und zum anderen fallen sie unter die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Jetzt ist in dieser Demiziererklärung.
Telemediendienste zur Kommunikationsgeeignet ist, das ist ein sehr offener Begriff, also es kann auch ein Blog sein, wo ich ein Kommentar schreibe, das kann bei eBay sein, wenn ich da irgendwie also überall, wo ich kommunizieren kann, gemeint sind, wahrscheinlich äh.
Diese Messengerdienste.
Aber das weiß man nicht ganz genau, wenn das so offen formuliert ist. Genau und das ist eben eine Ausweitung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf alles mögliche, ne? Auf Twitter, auf WhatsApp, aufs Rema, Signal, äh Facebook äh.
Und so weiter. Und ähm.
Na wo wir die
Pläne und auch die Forderungen gehen ja noch weiter, ne? Es geht ja eben auch um die Inhaltsdaten, also irgendwie Zugang zu verschlüsselter Kommunikation zu bekommen. Das Darknet, äh, habt ihr jetzt noch gar nicht erwähnt, was in den letzten Wochen ja auch äh relativ äh prominent äh gewesen ist, Ermittlungen im sogenannten Darknet ähm
wo man nicht genau weiß, äh, wie das eigentlich passiert ist, aber das findet sich ja in diesen Forderungen auch
also selbst die Bundespolizei, die jetzt äh verdeckt ermitteln darf, äh nach der jüngsten Erneuerung des Antiterrorgesetzes äh erwähnt, dass äh dass man sich eben äh in solchen Darknet-Foren äh,
bewegen können muss in polizeilichen Ermittlungen.
Jetzt wollten wir ja heute mal ein bisschen
ein Schwerpunkt drauf legen auf diese ganze, auf diesen ganzen Ist-Zustand, weil wir sind uns jetzt mit neuen Forderungen konfrontiert und mit ja teilweise ganz frischen Forderungen teilweise aber auch so mit verschärfenden erweiternden Forderungen. Dort sollen Systeme ausgebaut werden, äh
Datentöpfe sollen zusammengeführt werden, sagte glaube ich äh dem Maiziere wörtlich. Ähm und von daher wär's mal, glaube ich, mal ganz
äh wertvoll mal einen Blick dafür zu bekommen, was,
Was gibt's eigentlich schon? Und ähm was, was ist sozusagen auch die äh die Gemengelage, was es so ein bisschen state of the Art derzeit im Bereich Speicherung und äh Überwachung.
Matthias Wasser, da äh Einblicke.
Ja, ich kann's so ein bisschen beschreiben auf äh Ebene der Europäischen Union, wo es eben
große Datensysteme gibt, also dass äh große Informationssysteme gibt, das bekannteste ist das Schengeninformationssystem
wo Menschen gespeichert sind, die ähm
beispielsweise zur Festnahme ausgeschrieben sind, äh zur Ausreise ausgeschrieben sind, zur Fahnung ausgeschrieben sind, übrigens auch zur verdeckten Fahnung, also man das äh es gibt die Möglichkeit für die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden, dass man dort quasi
Namen meiner Person hinterlegen kann, äh die dann bei jeder Kontrolle oder bei einer Ausreise, wo das eben protokolliert wird, ähm, dann der ausschreibenden Behörde mitgeteilt wird und die überwachte Person merkt davon aber gar nichts.
Die Nutzung des schengenden Formationssystems,
steigt stetig an, vor allen Dingen die Nutzung dieser heimlichen Ausschreibung, das ist ganz interessant, ist sehr stark angestiegen, also vermutlich durch äh Inlandsgeheimdienste
beispielsweise aber das Schenken am Formationssystem äh bekommt auch neue Funktionen. Jetzt können dort Fingerabdrücke gespeichert werden.
Und geplant ist auch perspektivisch, dass dort äh die digitalen Gesichtsbilder,
im Moment schon dort äh optional gespeichert werden können, eine große Rolle bekommen und dann eben auch durchsuchbar sein sollen.
Gibt andere Datenbanken, die.
Dieses Schengen der Informationssystem ist aber jetzt nichts nichts brandneues.
Nee, das Schenken Informationssystem ist äh das älteste und größte Informationssystem.
Wie viel Leute sind da drin und wer kommt da rein?
Da kommst du rein, wenn du äh beispielsweise zur äh Ausreise ausgeschrieben bist, also eigentlich wurde es eingeführt, als das System äh um Verbrecher zu fangen, da so wurde es damals eigentlich auch beworben
größtenteils betrifft es aber Migrantinnen und Migranten, die eben äh abschiebepflichtig sind.
Also ausreisepflichtig sind und abzuschieben sind. Aber eben auch wenn du per Haftbefehl gesucht wirst oder Fahrzeuge auch, also nicht nur Personen, ähm, die dort ausgeschrieben sind, äh, zur Fahnung beispielsweise.
Ist wie gesagt das äh mächtigste System.
Und dann gibt es eben noch äh weitere Datenbanken, die quasi alle für einen speziellen Zweck errichtet sind. Also am wichtigsten ist, dass äh Visumsinformationssystem.
Wo eben.
Personen gespeichert sind, die im Visum beantragen, aber auch wer der Einlader ist zum Beispiel Kontaktdaten dazu,
Biometrische Daten der ähm der Antragsteller und Antragsteller beispielsweise.
Dann gibt es noch einen Fingerabdrucksystem der Europäischen Union, also wo man äh was man eingerichtet hat.
Zu dem Zweck, dass man verfolgen wollte, ob Leute vielleicht mehrere Asylanträge stellen und anhand der Fingerabdrücke eben äh festzustellen, nachher die Person und dann im äh anderen Namen.
Beispielsweise ein äh Asylantrag gestellt.
Dass es dieses Euro-Duck.
Ganz genau.
Euro DAC European Ductylos, Coupie.
Und,
diese Systeme hab ich schon gesagt, da sind alle für so 'n bestimmten Zweck eingerichtet, also man muss sozusagen zu einer bestimmten Personengruppe gehören, um in diesen äh Systemen gespeichert zu werden,
die werden ausgebaut, also ich hab von der Gesichtserkennung vorhin gesprochen, also Eurodac, das ist die, also biometrische Moment nur Fingerabdruckdatenbank, äh, wird ausgebaut als erste soll die eine Gesichtserkennungsfunktion erhalten. Also dort äh,
werden eben auch digitale Fotos der ähm dort gespeicherten Personen ähm,
verarbeitet und der Plan ist in einigen Jahren, also der Zeitrahmen ist äh zweitausend äh zweiundzwanzig glaube ich, wo das zur Verfügung stehen soll, dass dann dort eben auch nach Gesichtern gesucht werden kann.
Das ist im Prinzip kein Hexenwerk, also das BKA macht das auch schon in Deutschland, also in der Impulsdatenbank sind auch Gesichter gespeichert,
Und man kann theoretisch, wenn man jemanden sucht.
Je nachdem, wie gut das Ausgangsbild ist, also selbst im öffentlichen Nahverkehr sind die Kameras ja teilweise schon relativ hoch auflösend. Wenn man so ein Standbild hat, äh, kann das BKA in seiner Datenbank nach der betreffenden Person suchen.
Das ist limitiert, weil es äh dort noch nicht so viele Einträge gibt. Ähm,
Also nicht so viele äh heißt, dass es sozusagen äh noch nicht äh noch nicht zu jeder gespeicherten Person ein äh Foto gibt,
Und diese Funktion soll jetzt eben nach und nach eben auch in europäischen Datenbanken eingeführt werden. Eurotakt, Eurodac ist dann die erste,
und vermutlich wird die Visumsdatenbank die nächste sein und das Schenken der Fortionssystem.
Und das betrifft dann eben größtenteils Migrantinnen und Migranten. Woraus man äh
Schlussfolgern konnte, dass das wahrscheinlich äh eine der schwächsten Gruppen ist
an denen sich sowas eben ausprobieren lässt und auch ohne größeren Widerstand einführen lässt. Bei Eurodak war das ja auch so, also die erste biometrische Datenbank der Europäischen Union war eben,
eine Datenbank für Asylsuchende.
Das kann man ganz kurz noch auch mit dieser zu dieser Biometrie und Gesichtsdatenbank das hat er auch zu dem Berliner Erklärung und zu der Messias Erklärung gehört
dort eben diese Wunsch
quasi automatisierte Gesichtsdatenbank, also Datenbank mit Kameraüberwachung zu verknüpfen. Dazu gibt's auch schon Gespräche mit der Deutschen Bahn, Bundeskriminalamt, Bundespolizei und Innenministerium
Und das wollen sie eben.
Ist noch total unklar, was für Datenbanken bei rankommen und das BMI auch gesagt, ja, wissen wir noch nicht, müssen wir gucken und so, kommt da Fahndungsdatenbanken, dem ist er spricht selbst in der Pressekonferenz von, da wollen wir Verdächtige dann erkennen, äh
die irgendwo auftauchen, was natürlich total problematisch ist, äh aber nur so als also noch als diese zur deutschen Diskussion dazu, das ist natürlich auch so der
der Traum, ne? Das Innenministeriums, dass man einen automatischen Abgleich hat und die ganze Zeit weiß.
Ja und das ist auch der
schon angesprochene Ausbau dieser Datenbanken, also das hängende Informationssystem äh wird eben viel, hatte ich ja beschrieben zum zur heimlichen, zur verdeckten Fahndung genutzt und
Wenn man dort äh
quasi, wenn man drin ist im SES zwei, muss man irgendwas äh quasi es muss einen äh ganz bestimmten Grund geben, also man muss eben, ne, per Haftbefehl äh gesucht werden et cetera,
Und jetzt soll eine neue Kategorie eingerichtet werden und die ist relativ beliebig. Also Aktivitäten mit Terrorismusbezug.
Dass äh der Hintergrund ist, dass ähm rausgekommen ist, dass Menschen, die äh offensichtlich mit Anschlägen der letzten Monate zu tun hatten oder auch äh mutmaßliche Urheber gewesen sind.
Dass die schon äh in der Zeit vorher irgendwo beim Grenzübertritt angetroffen wurden. Aber man darf von nichts mitbekommen hat.
Und jetzt möchte man halt, dass solche Personen ähm wenn die beispielsweise in Bulgarien kontrolliert werden, äh dass dann Frankreich äh eine Nachricht bekommt
beispielsweise. Diese Personen sind aber vorher nicht verurteilt worden
die haben im Prinzip kein äh ähm kein Record äh von von irgendwas äh was sie gemacht haben sollen, sondern sie können auch Kontaktpersonen sein
Also ne,
Ähm äh Terrorismusbezug, Aktivitäten mit Tourismusbezug und das ist eine relativ äh weitgehende Maßnahme, die wird auch kommen, wird gerade nur diskutiert, wie man das hat, dann ein äh einheitlich macht
Und dann kann man eben äh Personen auch quasi nach gut dunken ausschreiben. Das ist.
Kann auch den Getränkehändler des Terroristen treffen oder was der da irgendwie.
Wenn du mit dem Kontakt hast, wenn du den vielleicht auffällig auch angerufen hast, äh, oder die ermittelnden Behörden davon ausgehen, äh, hm
Das ist äh Sinn machen würde, ähm dich äh zu bewachen oder dich auszuschreiben, kannst du darin landen. Der Punkt ist ja, dass diese ganzen Maßnahmen, die gerade zur Terrorismusbekämpfung eingeführt werden
werden alle mit sogenannten islamistischen Terrorismus begründet. Das ist ja relativ leicht verdaulich auch also angesichts der Anschläge
aber dieses die sind ja nicht daran gebunden, die Erweiterung äh also die Erweiterungen schengenden Formationssystem heißt eben Aktivitäten mit Terrorismusbezug und nicht
Aktivitäten mit islamistischem Terrorismusbezug. Das heißt also die gesamten Maßnahmen, die jetzt alle in Rede stehen und die auch umgesetzt werden, da bin ich ganz sicher, also da haben wir relativ äh wenig Chance, das zu verhindern. Können jederzeit auch gegen.
Andere Strömungen, sage ich mal, in Anschlag gebracht werden.
Vielleicht nochmal, um das so ein bisschen klar zu machen, ähm weil das glaube manche werden das auch das erste Mal so richtig gehört haben, dass es so etwas gibt wie ein Schengener Informationssystem. Ist das jetzt hier richtig äh überblicke,
gibt's im Prinzip dieses Informationssystem seit neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig.
Die äh daran teilnehmenden Staaten sind dann äh schrittweise äh gewachsen und mittlerweile sind es irgendwie, ja, alle sechsundzwanzig Mitglieder plus auch noch ähm also das Schengen.
Raum, so jetzt ist diese richtig Überblicke, also insgesamt achtundzwanzig äh Länder, die daran teilnehmen, unter anderem auch ähm Großbritannien im Übrigen, die ja sonst eigentlich mit Schengen äh relativ wenig am äh Hut haben,
Und dieses S hier ist hier ist zwei, was du einge äh angeführt hast. Das ist ja dann quasi seit zwanzig dreizehn.
Der neue Name und damit.
Das war die, das war der erste.
Lage geändert, ja? Genau und jetzt.
Ranken sich auch ganz interessante Geschichten drum. Also das hat äh äh an die zehn Jahre gedauert. Äh der Upgrade des Systems. Es ging eigentlich darum, mehr Mitgliedsstaaten brauchte sozusagen Erweiterung, dann ging's aber auch darum, da werden wir's schon mal weiterhin, dann sollte es auch mehr Funktionen bekommen. Fingerabdruck gespeichert, et cetera
gibt's auch noch ein paar lustige Fußnoten dazu. Es gab dann beispielsweise auch ein äh ein Hack des Systems an der dänischen Schnittstelle.
Für die dann ja ähm.
Leute aus dem schwedischen, aus dem äh Spektrum der Piratenpartei, dann auch in Maß gegangen sind. Ähm also das äh dieses äh Schenken-Informationssystem hat eine sehr lange Geschichte. Übrigens auch ähm,
Schwachstellen, also diese dänische Schnittstelle wurde von CSC äh Solutions äh installiert, die ja offensichtlich gute Kontakte auch zum äh US-Geheimdienst haben. Also
seit wie du sagst, seit über zwanzig Jahren bestehendes System, ist das Größte.
Und ähm dieses Visa-Informationssystem ist jetzt relativ neu. Das gibt's erst seit zweitausendelf.
Äh und was ist Euroduc? Äh, gibt's so ein bisschen länger alles irgendwie seit zweitausend am Start. Aber das sind jetzt im Prinzip alles noch,
separate Datenbanken, die alle sozusagen aus ihrer eigenen, außer einer eigenen Rechtsgrundlage heraus oder eigenen Bedarfssituationen separat voneinander entwickelt worden.
Genau, das wurde nach und nach erweitert, also regelmäßig wird die Verordnung geändert, dann gibt's äh quasi so Salami-Taktikmäßige schrittweise Erweiterungen und das Neue ist jetzt die Zusammenlegung der Datentöpfe, das ist also.
Viele gibt's denn, wie viele Datenbanken sind denn noch mehr oder als jetzt.
Es sind noch mehr, also ich weiß nicht ähm wie weit wir das vertiefen wollen. Es gibt zum Beispiel noch äh ein sogenanntes äh Strafregistersystem, wo die Urteile ähm äh quasi europaweit äh abrufbar sind
Chris Heißers EC RIS. Was auch biometrische Daten speichert.
Also wenn von der sogenannten Zusammenlegung der Datentöpfe geredet wird, dann sind im in der Regel diese vier Datenbanken gemeint. Wir haben ja noch nichts über die kommenden Datenbanken gesagt. Wir haben nur über die bestehenden Da.
Den Stand der Dinge ja.
Und das ist quasi der Plan äh ja also Datentöpfe, wie meint der Maizier das eigentlich? Die Idee ist so ein Kernsystem zu machen.
Dass alle,
bestehenden und zukünftigen äh ähm Informationssysteme angeschlossen werden, also das ist quasi so eine zentrale Sammlung von allen biometrischen und allen Kerndaten gibt,
Also zu den Kerndaten gehören wahrscheinlich die äh also Personendaten,
Name Anschrift und eben die mymetrischen Daten, dass immer, wenn ein neuer Datensatz eingestellt wird.
Eine Software im Hintergrund äh existieren diese Fingerabdrücke schon,
welche der fing vorhandenen Fingerabdrücke oder Gesichtsbilder haben die beste Qualität und welches behalten wir
Das ist so ein bisschen äh wird als Qualitätssicherung beschrieben. Also es geht ja bei diesen ganzen Datenbanken viel um mehr Quantität, aber auch mehr Qualität.
Dass die Formate stimmen beispielsweise und das ist tatsächlich ein deutsches Projekt,
die Zusammenlegung dieser Datentöpfe mit der Einrichtung eines Kernsystems. Ganz interessant ist, die Europäische Kommission hat dazu im März ein lange angekündigtes Papier vorgelegt
Also wie man die äh Datenlandschaft der Europäischen Union sozusagen weiterentwickeln will.
Und äh das Papier wurde zwei Wochen äh verzögert, weil nämlich zwischendrin de Maizire sein Forderungspapier vorgelegt hat und gesagt hat, wir müssen aber dieses Kernsystem machen
brauchen diese Zusammenlegung der Datentöpfe und schwupp fand sich dann in der verspäteten Vorstellung dieses Kommissionspapier auch genau diese Forderung.
Kerndatensystem.
Mal eine Frage zu, wer soll denn eigentlich dann auf dieses äh System Zugriff haben? Sind es dann die Polizeien, Europol oder wie ist das geregelt? Kommt auch Geheimdienste ran.
Also die Zugriffe werden erweitert, also im Moment äh ist es auch ähm je nachdem, je nach äh Datenbank äh äh unterschiedlich. Also das sind teilweise zum Beispiel auch die Ausländerbehörden,
Ne, sind ja also grenzpolizeiliche Datenbanken im Wesentlichen, ähm, die dann beispielsweise Zugriff haben
Aber auch die Polizei, also gutes Beispiel ist eben wieder Eurodac, also das ist diese biometrische Datenbank mit Fingerabdrücken und zukünftig auch Gesichtsbildern
Und da hat man dann festgestellt, äh die Verordnung ist eigentlich zu äh zu eng, da haben sich dann die äh Straffolge gewehrt und haben gesagt,
Wir haben hier eine riesen Datenbank mit Fingerabdrücken und die benutzen wir nur, um Asylanträge abzugleichen. Äh wir,
als im Bereich von Ermittlungen, wollen aber auch Zugriff auf diese Fingerabdrücke haben. Äh dürfen das aber nicht, weil der Zweck halt relativ eng ist.
Und dann wurde die Verordnung eben schwuppdachträulich geändert und jetzt haben eben die Strafverfolgungsbehörden der Mitgliedsstaaten auch Zugriff auf Eurodac.
Beispielsweise. Und so wurden eben die Verordnung äh auch Schritt für Schritt erweitert und wie das dann gemacht werden soll mit diesen mit diesen Datentöpfen, das ist alles noch ein bisschen unklar, weil äh es wird gesagt, na ja,
die Zukunftsrechte und auch die Datenbesitzer bleiben erhalten.
Also man muss sich das ja so vorstellen, wenn beispielsweise das BKA seine Daten auf europäischer Ebene teilt, bleibt es trotzdem, Datenbesitzerin.
Und die anderen, die auf die Daten zugreifen müssen, dass nach den festgelegten Kriterien machen,
Wenn man jetzt aber Datenbanken zusammenlegt, äh ist so ein bisschen die Frage, ja aber auf welche dieser Daten darf dann welche Behörde zugreifen. Das ist alles äh
relativ unklar und da gibt es aber gerade eine hochrangige Expertenkommission, wenn man auf EU-Ebene, also äh solche Pläne ähm forciert, dann gibt es ähm.
Äh immer solche ähm sogenannten Experten äh Kommissionen und die, die jetzt eingerichtet wurde zu dem Thema äh soll die interoperabilität der Datenbanken,
untersuchen und äh Vorschläge vorlegen
also ne? Interoperabilität klingt jetzt ja erstmal relativ harmlos, aber da drin steckt genauso diese Zusammenlegung ähm Qualitätssicherung äh et cetera.
Wir haben ja noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen äh was noch kommt. Also es gibt ja
diverse Datenbanken, die gerade in der Mache sind auf europäischer Ebene. Und da verabschiedet man sich auch von dem Prinzip, dass also Leute zu irgendeiner bestimmten Bevölkerungsgruppe gehören müssen, Asylsuchende, Visa-Antragstellerinnen, Antragsteller
oder Straftäter meinetwegen und die kommten Datenbanken,
betreffen im Prinzip alle. Da musst du also nichts äh dir zu Schulden kommen lassen haben, also relativ bekannt im Netzpolitischen Bereich ist ja die Passagierdatenbank, die europäische.
PNR, wo es ja auch äh seit langem Kampagne gibt.
Und ähm auch die ist äh umgesetzt worden äh nach den Anschlägen, also das EU-Parlament hat da ähm große Bedenken gehabt und es schien so, dass das keine Zustimmung findet. Äh nach den Parisanschlägen vom November letzten Jahres ist äh diese Hürde dann auch gefallen. Äh das ist beschlossen
und äh da gab es dann ähm die Forderung von Frankreich.
Unter anderem, dass nicht nur internationale Flüge davon erfasst werden, sondern auch europäische.
Was ich zum Hintergrund vielleicht nochmal, es gibt ja diese Passagierdatensysteme schon, diesen Austausch,
Den gibt es übrigens im Prinzip zwischen allen Ländern auf zum mit so einem relativ schmalen Datensatz
PNR Datensatzes aber eben enthält weiterhin mehr Datenfelder. Und so ein Abkommen hat ja die USA sich ausbedungen mit Australien gibt's das beispielsweise auch schon äh andere Länder fordern das auch,
Jetzt wollte die EU sowas eben auch haben und ursprünglich sollte das nur internationale Flüge betreffen, also ankommende.
In die EU.
Und äh dann kam aber der Vorschlag oder die Forderung aus einigen Mitgliedsstaaten unter Frankreich. Nein, wir wollen auch innereuropäische Flüge davon erfassen. Das schien sich nicht durchzusetzen im endgültigen Regelungs äh in der endgültigen Regelung
steht dann drin, die Mitgliedsstaaten können optional auch in europäische Flüge erfassen,
und äh so wird es jetzt auch gemacht. Also dieses Forderungspapier Deutschland Frankreich, äh was ja im Prinzip eine Sammlung von Maximalforderungen ist, sagt wir wollen äh.
Inlandsflüge streht er sogar drin.
Genau und sogar Inlandsflüge. Ähm innerhalb dieses Passagierdatensystems erfassen.
Dann gibt es noch äh es gibt weitere Pläne für Datenbanken, also es gibt ähm den Plan ein sogenanntes äh Ein- und Ausreisesystem zu machen.
Das äh bedeutet, dass alle nicht EU-Staatsangehörigen ähm,
bei der Einreise ähm quasi äh ihre Daten äh abgeben müssen, also ihre Daten gespeichert werden, auch äh biometrische Daten, die ja meistens in den Fessen äh in den neueren Pässen, in den.
Biometrischen Pässen schon äh drin sind, die werden ausgelesen und gespeichert. Ähm da.
Ist im Moment ein bisschen Debatte drum, wie viel da gespeichert werden soll, sollen es vier Fingerdrücke, acht Fingerdrücke oder Zehn-Finger-Abdrücke unters Gesichtsbild sein oder sollen es nur vier äh Fingerabdrücke und das Gesichtsbild sein.
Arbeitstitel zu diesem.
ES heißt das, European äh eine ähm System, ES ähm ein und Ausreisesystem.
Und da mischen sich jetzt auch die Polizei hinein und die sagen, na ja Moment, wenn wir jetzt schon hier eine neue biometrische Datenbank errichten, dann wird das schon mit zehn Finger abdrücken.
Dann sagen aber die Grenzpolizeien ja wartet mal, also wenn wir jetzt die Fingerabdrücke abnehmen müssen,
dann ist es für uns viel besser, wir müssen nur vier Abdrücke abnehmen, das geht der Grenzübertritt viel schneller
als uns mit zehn Fingerdrücken aus äh aufhalten zu müssen. Also so diese Debatten gibt es gerade, das System wird aber kommen auf jeden Fall. Also das ist klar.
Und auch da fordern Demazire und Gazny in diesem Papier äh die Maximalforderung, nämlich Frankreich hat letztes Jahr gesagt.
Ähm also dieses System äh firmierte früher als intelligente Grenzen. Smartboarders. Der Begriff wird nicht mehr benutzt.
Und.
Ist das jetzt der neue Begriff? Ist dann Identitätsmanagement oder.
Smart Boarders ist eigentlich ein Paket gewesen, äh wozu auch noch so ein äh Bevorzugungssystem gehörte. Ähm die Idee war, dass man äh sozusagen viel Reisende können ihre Daten freiwillig schon vorher abgeben.
Auch ihre biometrischen Daten und kriegen dann einen Tauken,
mit dem sie dann quasi diskret viel diskreter viel schneller die Grenze übertreten können. Davon hat man sich verabschiedet und übrig geblieben ist jetzt nur noch dieses ein Ausreisesystem im Moment.
Und ähm Frankreich hat dann gesagt, na ja, aber wenn wir jetzt schon so eine große biometrische Datenbank äh von allen Menschen machen, die die EU-Grenze übertreten.
Dann sollen auch die Grenzübertritte der EU-Staatsangehörigen davon erfasst werden.
Und dann haben sie das lustigerweise haben sie das intelligent intelligente Grenzen für alle genannt diesen Vorschlag,
also so quasi als wär's ein Stück Gerechtigkeit, wenn eben nicht nur die EU.
Drittstaatenangehörigen, der davon erfasst würden, sondern auch äh alle achtundzwanzig Mitgliedsstaaten plus schenken, das weiß ich. Ähm.
Und äh auch da wird jetzt in diesem Papier äh ist in diesem Papier davon die Rede, also Deutschland war da eigentlich dagegen oder hat sich zumindest sehr distanziert geäußert zu diesem Smartboarders für All.
Und in dem Forderungspapier steht jetzt drin
dass Deutschland diese Forderung eben beispielsweise auch unterstützt. Und das ist aber immer noch nicht das Ende der Fahnenstange, also ich hab jetzt diese Passagierdatensystem erwähnt, ich hab das ein Ausreisesystem erwähnt.
Ähm und jetzt äh gibt es noch das Problem der ähm.
Also das ist sozusagen ein Plan. Ich äh schaue hier gerade auf so ein, so ein äh Dokument der Europäischen Kommission, wo sie das hier propagieren.
Es gibt den zweiten Vorschlag jetzt inzwischen.
Ja. Weiß jetzt nicht, ob.
Der jetzt diskutiert wird. Der zweite Richtlinienvorschlag.
Genau, hier ist irgendwie dann auch von einer, verstehe es noch nicht so ganz genau, sie wollen aufzeichnen, Date and Place of Entry and Exit, also wo man reine, wo man.
Der Hintergrund ist.
Neunzig Tage in jeglicher hundertachtzig Tage Periode.
Der Hintergrund ist ähm es wurde eigentlich auch als so ein äh ähm Grenz äh äh grenzbehördliches Informationssystem äh quasi eigentlich mal äh initiiert.
Dass nämlich ähm sogenannte Overstayers aufspüren sollte, also Menschen, die mit irgendeinem Aufenthaltstitel, also einem Visum einreisen, was meinetwegen neunzig Tage da geht. Ähm aber die EU nicht wieder verlassen.
Die meisten Mitgliedsstaaten haben solche eigenen Systeme
aber dann taucht die Frage auf, was ist zum Beispiel, wenn jemand in Spanien einreist ähm und die U über Polen wieder verlässt,
Das wird nicht protokoliert und man weiß also nicht, wie man möchte sozusagen eine Art Buchhaltung haben, wie viele Menschen halten sich ohne Aufenthaltstitel in der Europäischen Union aus? Auf. So wurde das System äh eigentlich mal beworben.
Ähm und auch dir auch der Zweck äh wurde daneben erweitert.
Für dieses System, also ich hatte das mit dem Fingerabdrücken äh gesagt, also die äh Polizei will also nicht nur die Grenz äh Behörden, die Ausländerbehörden sollen darauf zugreifen dürfen, sondern auch die Polizei, man will das jetzt anders machen, als bei dem Fingerabdruck äh Informationssystem
wo die Polizei dann später da reingeholt wurde, sondern äh auf dieses neue System sollen eben alle Zugriff bekommen.
Ja. Und es soll dann auch irgendwie den Pass ersetzen für.
Ja äh das ähm.
EU. Also nicht für Europäer, aber also nicht für EU-Europäer, sondern eben für Leute, die
reinkommen und dann sozusagen auch gleich mit dem Visa-Prozess in den in den in den in den Botschaften und Konsulaten quasi auch funktionieren.
Die Rede ist davon, den äh äh lieb gewonnenen Stempel abzuschaffen. Da gibt es aber noch Widerstände, also dass äh quasi die ähm
in den maschinenlesbaren Pässen äh quasi hinterlegt wird äh die Aufenthaltsdauer, dass das eben auch äh immer automatisch ausgelesen werden kann.
Das ist quasi auch das wie das Visum selber digital im Dokument abgespeichert wird. Mhm.
Ähm nochmal eine andere zu Grenzen ging, der enthält diese diese deutsch-französische Erklärung ein Passus, den ihr nicht genau entschlüsseln konnte. Da ging's darum, wir wollen den freien Personen und Warenverkehr erhalten
Und dann kommt aber, um an den Binnengrenzen lagerangepasste Kontrollen unterhalb der Schwelle von flächendenkenden Grenzkontrollen durchführen zu können. Also nicht die großen Staus auf dem Brenner quasi. Brauchen wir ein rechtliches Instrumentarium, um mit damit Grenzkontrollen wieder eingeführt werden können
in flexiblere Weise
besser an die terroristische Bedrohung, was ist das? Ist das sowas wie alle EU-Bürger kriegen so eine, so eine fährt so automatisch durch mit so einem,
Chip und wird nicht so richtig, wird auch kontrolliert, aber halt nicht auf so einer.
Grenzer äh äh also nicht so so auffällig oder was ist das.
Na, diese Forderung geht eigentlich ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung. Also das hat natürlich auch mit den Datenbanken zu tun, äh mit denen man die Leute dann abgleichen möchte. Aber diese Forderung geht eigentlich in die Richtung
der Wiedereinführung von Bin ganz Kontrollen. Hm, das äh äh ist ja bekannt, dass einigen Mitgliedsstaaten Deutschland was auch gemacht haben.
Dass äh da müsste man vielleicht noch ein Stück weiter ausholen, äh das fing eigentlich nach dem sogenannten arabischen Frühling an, dass man so mitbekommen hat, äh oh äh,
die Grenzen oder die Diktatoren wie Benalin, Tunesien fallen
und die Leute fangen an überzusetzen in die Europäische Union und ihre Reisefreiheit quasi wahrnehmen zu wollen und da haben zweitausendzwölf dann unter anderem Deutschland und Frankreich dafür gesorgt, dass der Schengener Grenzkodex geändert wird
Also Binnengrenzen sind ja richtig verboten. Also ein Staat äh,
wird sozusagen auch belangt, wenn irgendwo noch eine Schranke steht. Man darf das nicht mehr haben.
Eine der großen Errungenschaften der EU, ne?
Eigentlich die größte Freizügigkeit und es gab eine Möglichkeit, Grenzkontrollen vorübergehend wieder einzuführen.
Äh davon wurde Gebrauch gemacht bei solchen Geschichten wie Gipfelprotesten beispielsweise oder Sportereignissen. Es musste aber einen Anlass geben
übrigen Mitgliedsstaaten mussten vorher informiert werden und das wurde geändert, es gibt 'ne neue Möglichkeit, die schenkenden Ganzkontrollen wieder einzuführen und zwar
Wenn ein Mitgliedsstaat der Europäischen Union einer äh ich weiß nicht genau, warum die EU nicht äh über großen
im übergroßen Migrationsansturm sozusagen ausgesetzt ist, dann können andere Mitgliedsstaaten,
Die Binnengrenzen wieder kontrollieren, das war auf Griechenland und Italien gemünzt, also wenn dort viele Migranten ankommen, möchten wir hier die Möglichkeit haben, äh die bei deren Weiterreise zu verhindern.
Oder Österreich halt.
Das ist ein Hintergrund von dem, was du angesprochen hast.
Der andere ist äh dass im Rahmen dieser Freizügigkeit äh an äh EU-Außengrenzen EU Staatsangehörige nicht.
Tief, also systematisch kontrolliert werden dürfen, also,
Wir drei, die hier sitzen, also ich vermute mal, dass hier auch eine äh Staatsangehörigkeit eines UEU-Mitgliedschafts habt. Wir haben quasi das Privileg, wenn wir die EU-Außengrenze übertreten, dass wir nicht systematisch kontrolliert werden dürfen,
höchstens darf geguckt werden, ist unser Reisedokument echt,
und stimmt das sozusagen mit unserem Foto überein? Das ist quasi 'ne normale oberflächliche Kontrolle und man darf das vielleicht noch mit den wichtigsten Datenbanken abgleichen. Schenken Informationssystem beispielsweise.
Und mit dieser Änderung äh wurden eben diese ähm also dies betrifft die Kontrollen an den Binnengrenzen, äh dass die äh wieder möglich sein sollen und eben systematische Kontrollen an den europäischen Außengrenzen
Plus mit dem Abgleich möglichst vieler Datenbanken
Also da kommt wieder dieser, da kommt wieder Demaziere mit seinen Datentöpfen ins Spiel. Ein Ziel ist nämlich auch, dass es eine einheitliche Suchmaske geben soll
Also im Moment äh gibt es nur so ein kleines Set an äh
EU-Datenbanken oder auch Interpooldatenbanken, die beim Grenzübertritt abgefragt werden ähm und zukünftig soll sozusagen äh die Abfragen der Polizei über ein Single Search Interface, äh, Zugriff auf äh
alle wesentlichen Datenbanken haben und das wird das Kernsystem sein,
dem Maisier geredet hat, äh, Plus sozusagen noch ein paar extra Features, plus das Passagierdatensystem, das ein Ausreisesystem und Interpuldatenbanken.
So verständnismäßig ähm da nochmal nachzuhaken. Wenn ich jetzt Schengenraum verlasse am Flughafen. Aber man fliegt nach UK.
Dann gibt's ja da eine Passkontrolle und die äh Herren von, ich weiß gar nicht, wer das dann ist. Polizeizoll, ich weiß gar nicht, welche.
Welche Mützenträger da sozusagen jetzt konkret äh mit der Passkontrolle beauftragt sind.
Nehmen wir dann in der Regel den Pass und lesen den Maschinen des Badenteil mit einem Computer ein, ziehen den durch, haben dann so eine Schweigesekunde, schauen irgendwie auf den Bildschirm. So da irgendwie einen, kannst du das irgendwie mal.
Verständlich machen, was da in dem Moment geprüft werden darf oder wird. Also welche Datenbanken kommen in so einem Moment heute schon zum Tragen.
Also wenn du jetzt äh also für Großbritannien kann ich das nicht so genau sagen, aber äh wenn man's jetzt zum Beispiel umgekehrt machen würde bei der Einreise nach Deutschland, wird dann werden halt deutsche Datenbanken abgefragt, das ist äh ähm im Wesentlichen Impul.
Man so als äh also die die größte Datei der inneren Sicherheit ist in Deut.
Polizei, Datenbank vor.
Wo
Personen.
Was eine Verbunddatei ist, wo auch die die Länder angeschlossen sind. Also die wird beim BKA geführt, aber auch die Länder haben dort äh Lesenden und Schreiben den Zugriff. Ähm beispielsweise das Schengen-Informationssystem wird abgefragt.
Ähm,
und äh was neu ist, wird jetzt äh ist jetzt auch die verpflichtende Abfrage von äh Interpuldatenbank nach äh gestohlenen oder vermissten äh Reisedokumenten. So eine internationale, große Datenbank, die jetzt.
Die hatten wir noch nicht diese Stolen entlastet Travel Docturbins, also sozusagen alte ich habe meinen Führerschein verloren oder ich habe meinen Pass verloren et cetera. Ok.
Und das soll eben auch erweitert werden, dass beim Grenzübertritt äh quasi äh auch die noch zu errichtenden Datenbanken äh abgefragt werden äh und,
dann auch eben letztlich Eurodac oder das Visumsdaten äh System faktisch, weil wenn beispielsweise ähm äh ein Name abgefragt wird, äh ähm.
Über dieses noch zu errichtende Kernsystem und dann wird ein Eintrag in Eurolack gefunden, äh, beispielsweise wird ja faktisch eben auch Eurodac äh abgefragt. Also das ist alles noch ein bisschen in der Mache. Da muss man mal gucken, wie die das umsetzen, also ähm.
Ja
Aber derzeit sind es im Prinzip diese drei Datenbanken, die die gecheckt werden bei so beim Eintritt von Non Nonching nach nach Schengen
also im Falle von Deutschland, in Polen, im Falle anderer Länder dann entsprechende nationale Polizei äh Sachen, dann diese Stolen in Lost Travel Documents und äh das Schengener Informationssystem, was wir ja eingangs schon.
Das sind die, die äh in Deutschland auf jeden Fall abgefragt werden. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob nicht auch heute schon äh beispielsweise Eurodac abgefragt wird.
Aber Fingerabdrücke sind ja in dem Sinne nicht.
Aber du kannst ja quasi äh ähm auch den Namen abfragen und äh eben gucken, ob du, ob da irgendwas vorliegt, äh, gegen die Person. Aber es macht keinen Sinn letztlich. Also ich glaube, es sind die drei, die wir jetzt aufgezählt haben.
Okay. Und dieses Visa-Informationssystem, das ist okay, das ist jetzt nur für Leute, die ein Visum haben sozusagen.
Oder die Einladung.
Die Einladung der Heike, die wurde doch damals im Kuhhandel, oder? Gab's da nicht? Diese Visa-Warndatei, die gibt's doch auch noch deutschlandweit irgendwie, wo die Menschen, die äh Menschen einladen und dann kriegst du da irgendwie eine
Wenn du, wenn die Leute zu oft irgendwie sich hier irgendwie auf einmal einwandern oder irgendwie abtauchen, kriegst du so einen Sperrvermerk rein und darfst niemanden mehr einladen,
Das hat die FDP getauscht gegen die gegen gegen eine andere Datenbank oder gegen so eine innere Sicherheitsnummer, die populäre war. Na ja, weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Also in der WG Pedia steht dazu zum ersten Juni zwanzig dreizehn hat Deutschland eine zentrale Visa Warndatei errichtet, hier werden alle Menschen erfasst, die schon einmal wegen Visum relevanter Straftaten aufgefallen sind.
Worüber wir jetzt noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, ist äh noch eine weitere Datenbank, die auf europäischer Ebene die Mache in der Mache ist.
Es ist nämlich so ein äh Reiseanmeldungssystem. Wir kennen das beispielsweise aus den USA.
Und das betrifft äh die Visum-Freireisenden.
Da ähm hat man nämlich äh das Problem, dass die in den Datenbanken in den bis jetzt genannten Datenbanken ja irgendwie durchschlüpfen und man möchte aber auch.
Dass die quasi ähm äh registriert beziehungsweise abgeglichen werden können mit Datenbanken.
Und das äh Kurzel dafür ist ET, IAS, äh, European Travel, Information auf Horization System und da,
sollen, dann äh auch die Visum frei einreisenden vor der Einreise sich anmelden.
Also da weiß man jetzt noch nichts, äh in welcher Frist, äh, es wurde aber 'ne Onlineanmeldung sein und nach den gegenwärtigen Vorschlägen soll man da nicht nur sagen, äh.
Ne, wie ich heiße, mit welchem Flug ich komme meinetwegen oder vielleicht noch Passdaten.
Sondern man soll auch sachdienliche Informationen zum geplanten Reiseweg hinterlegen.
Ob sich das durchsetzt, äh, weiß ich nicht. Im Moment kommen aber immer die Maximalforderungen zum Tragen, also ich vermute ja, das heißt, ähm, dass die Leute dann eben quasi auch ähm äh.
Wo wollen sie, wann sein? Also wie detailliert das jetzt ist, ob man da dann auch die Hotelbuchung eintragen soll oder nicht. Vielleicht nochmal dazu.
Sag mal, wie heißt das Ding genau? ETIRS A. ET.
Ethias European Frevel information out of Arization System.
Ich glaub die deutsche Übersetzung ist europäisches Informations und.
Reiseinformation.
Reiseautorisierungssystem oder so ähnlich. Und wir kennen das ja schon aus den USA, dieses Esta-System und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das hier im Podcast schon hattet, aber es gab ja.
Vorschlag, äh, Social Media, Onlinepräsenzen, äh, zu hinterlegen. Das ist im Moment, also in den USA.
Das ist im Moment noch nicht umgesetzt, ist das so äh auch so eine Art Vorstufe, also die ähm äh Einwanderungsbehörde hat da quasi so einen Debattenvorschlag gemacht, äh der da auch kontrovers ist äh in den USA,
aber und sie haben gesagt, na ja optional, also man kann es auch verweigern, natürlich.
Wobei logisch ist, äh wäre es verweigert, ähm wird wahrscheinlich im Scoring äh im Risiko Scoring einen Minuspunkt bekommen, aber es kann sein, dass äh sowas in einem europäischen System äh,
dann auch eingeführt wird. Vielleicht.
Geben sie bitte ihren Twitter-Account, ihren Facebook, Instagram.
Leicht noch nicht im ersten Vorschlag. Äh also das ist wie gesagt im Moment noch eine Debatte. Das System wird aber kommen ganz bestimmt.
Mit welchen Features sozusagen, welchem Umfang, das ist relativ unklar, das ist gerade in der Mache.
Und äh ja und weshalb ich das jetzt alles so ausgeführt habe. Also ne, die die ursprünglichen Datenbanken, man musste halt quasi irgendeine bestimmte äh irgendeiner bestimmten Gruppe zugehören und äh ähm
dieses Prinzip hat man verlassen mit der Passagierdatenbank, mit dem Ein- und Ausreisesystem äh mit dem.
Äh mit diesem äh Autorisierungssystem und auf all diese Systeme äh all diese Systeme sollen zukünftig zu den Datentöpfen gehören.
Das ist eigentlich so das neue Plus, das äh auch schon erwähnte Strafregistersystem.
Es sind noch ein paar kleine in der Mache, also ähm es soll zum Beispiel auch einen europäischen Kriminalaktennachweis geben. Also eine Kriminalakte ist eine Ermittlungsakt.
Also das unterscheidet sich vom Strafregister dadurch, dass das Strafregister ist eben ein Urteil,
und die Kriminalakte äh ist äh Ermittlungen. Also man soll quasi europäischen äh also äh unter dem EU-Mitgliedsstaaten auf den äh zugreifen können äh gegen wen wurde äh oder wird äh wegen irgendwas ermittelt,
Wenn man zum Beispiel selbst Ermittlungen betreibt, äh Lin.
Sieht man ja hier, wie gut sowas funktioniert, wenn dann äh Leute
irgendwann mal eine Ermittlung hatten, zehn Jahre später in der Polizeikontrolle geraten und das dann
genutzt wird um zu sagen ja das ist jetzt vielverdächtiger weil hatte mal 'ne Ermittlungsverfahren wegen XY auch wenn das Verfahren eingestellt wurde, dass er irgendwie
zeigt sich also diese Ermittlungs diese Daten.
Wissen, geht in Richtung der Störerdatei, für die Deutschland sich immer wieder einsetzt auf europäischer Ebene? Und äh ja,
Also diese ganzen einzelnen Datenbanken, die dümpeln ja nicht nur vor sich hin. Da kommt nämlich jetzt Europol ins Spiel
Europol ist die Europäische Polizeiagentur, die äh in den Jahren seit Gründung, also es ist ein bisschen unklar, wer die Gründung von Europol äh wird unterschiedlich datiert
glaube offiziell war es neunundneunzig als,
Drogen, europäisches Drogenbüro, also das war quasi der erste Auftrag in Europol hatte, das wurde dann auch äh schrittweise erweitert.
Und inzwischen ist Europoleben für alle Formen organisierter Kriminalität und Terrorismus zuständig
Ähm Europol äh beobachtet das Internet, Europol kontrolliert das Internet, äh eure Pol lässt Internetinhalte entfernen, meldet die bei den Providern äh zur Entfernung,
nicht nur zu Terrorismus, sondern inzwischen auch zu Migration, also Facebook Accounts von äh Fluchthelfern, die halt.
Wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil in der Türkei angesiedelt sind,
ne? Für syrische Flüchtlinge werden offline genommen. Äh solche Geschichten et cetera, was uns jetzt aber hier interessiert, ist das Europol quasi der Broker dieser ganzen äh Daten wird.
Europoler hält selbst immer mehr Zugang zu den Datenbanken, also im Moment äh nur aufs SIS.
Bei Eurodac und Visumsinformationssysteme, das ist aber nur eine technische Frage, es fehlt die Schnittstelle, die Erlaubnis zu Zugriff hatteuropol schon und was Europol jetzt machen soll, ist den Massenabgleich der Daten.
Um dort Kreuztreffer zu suchen. Also ähm.
Äh Batchverarbeitung äh wird das in den Papieren genannt, also stapelweise Verarbeitung der Daten, das heißt Europol ähm soll eben in den großen Datenbanken, das wird.
Im Moment das Schenkelfarbationssystem sein, Eurodack und das Wieseninformationssystem äh soll diese Daten abgleichen mit den eigenen Datenbank.
Und diese hatten diese Europul-Datenbanken haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Äh das sind äh ist ein sehr, sehr großes Informationssystem, unterteilt sich auch nochmal in so,
einzelne Aspekte, also bei Europol gibt es eine ganze Datensammlung zu Cyberkriminellen, da gibt es eine zu äh islamistischen Terroristen, zu nichtislamistischen Terroristen. Ähm.
Zu äh also es gibt ich glaube zweiundzwanzig verschiedene Unterdatenbanken und es gibt es große Europol-Informationssystem,
Und was Europoleben machen soll, ist, äh, sich die ganzen Daten äh der anderen Datenbanken hernehmen und die abgleichen mit dem eigenen Informationssystem, um dort nach Auffälligkeiten zu suchen,
Und da trappen wir jetzt alle im Dunkeln, was bedeutet das denn eigentlich? Also auf welche konkreten Daten hat Europol der Zugriff.
Also hat Europol dann zum Beispiel auch Zugriff auf äh meinetwegen in einem Haftbefehl äh hinterlegten IP-Adressen.
Oder hat eure Pole auch Zugriff äh auf Einlader von äh Visa-Antragsstellen.
Beispielsweise auf die Fingerdrucke beispielsweise, also ähm welche Daten werden mit welchen Daten abgeglichen.
Und ist das nicht eigentlich eine Rasterfahndung, die Europul da macht?
Und der Plan ist eigentlich auch das zu automatisieren, also dass dieser dieser Abgleich quasi in Echtzeit passiert.
Da kommt dann wieder das Bundeskriminalamt ins Spiel, das Deutsche, die nämlich sehr daran interessiert sind, äh die technischen Lösungen bereitzustellen.
Also die an Forschungsprojekten beteiligt sind, dass die Formate stimmen, dass die standalisiert sind für diesen Austausch beispielsweise, damit er überhaupt äh vernünftig stattfinden kann. Ähm, dass bei Europol bestimmte Datenbanken eingerichtet werden.
Ähm für diesen Abgleich, dass es äh Kommunikationssysteme gibt, äh für diesen Abgleich und das äh kommt jetzt gerade, diese Massenabgleich, diese Kreuztreffersuche.
Und das hat meines Erachtens eine ziemlich große Bedeutung auch für Datenschutz, weil Europol dadurch eine Rolle übernimmt, die es eigentlich gar nicht haben darf, also.
Das vielleicht auch nochmal als Fußnote, die Europäische Union unterliegt auch diesem sogenannten äh Subsidiaritätsprinzip, also die darf eigentlich keine Sachen installieren, die in den Mitgliedsstaaten äh schon vorhanden sind.
Weil man sonst sozusagen, ne? Das äh unterlaufen würde, sondern sie soll
Das betrifft auch die polizeilichen Maßnahmen. Äh darf nur Sachen machen, die einen Mehrwert erzielen und die quasi so eine Art äh ich sage mal Koordinationsfunktion haben. Ein Europol wird hier aber zur Behörde für die Rasserfahndung
quasi.
Werden diese Daten dann äh von bei Europol auch nochmal gefüttert von den einzelnen Mitglieds äh äh Ländern.
Ja ja natürlich, die Europol, äh, alle Daten, die bei Europol äh liegen, kommen aus den Staaten. Nee, nicht nur, also Europol sammeln natürlich auch selber.
Also im Bereich des Internets zum Beispiel Europa hat eine eigene Abteilung um das Internet zu beobachten und zu durchsuchen. Ähm.
Und die werden natürlich dort auch in Neuropoldatenbank gespeichert.
Was äh noch nicht gefallen ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob's äh eine Bedeutung hat, aber es gibt ja für den Betrieb dieser ganzen europäischen Datenbanken auch noch eine eigene Agentur dafür, diese.
EU-Lisa.
Ulisa, genau, eine Agentur für große IT-Systeme. Also was heißt das genau,
Management of Large, Skale, IT Systems in the Area of Freedom, Security and justers. Das klingt doch schön, oder?
In Estland sitzt und die betreibt halt dieses Schengensystem, die betreibt dieses Visa äh System ja genau inzwischen seitdem bist du zusammen Schengen, also SCS zwei, nach der Umstellung sozusagen, haben die das äh übernommen,
und ähm.
Offenbar ein Eurodac ist auch dort untergebracht und offenbar so doch dieses Entrixit-System äh dort Fußfassen.
Künftigen werden auch dort angesiedelt werden.
Dann ist hier noch von einem Registrierungsprogramm RTP die Rede.
Ja das ist das, was äh im Moment nicht mehr also was zu diesem Smartboarders Paket gehörte,
dieser Trocken, also ich gebe meine Fingerdrücke freiwillig ab, äh, hinterlege das in europäischen Datenbank und kriege dadurch
Es war so ein bisschen die Frage, wie soll diese Trockenen aussehen, soll das eine Chipkarte sein, soll das so ein, ne, wie wir das also wirk
so ein regelrechten Tauken bekommen. Äh davon hat man sich verabschiedet und dieses elektronische Anmeldesystem ist so ein bisschen der
wird wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen der Satz davon werden.
Was ich mich jetzt die ganze Zeit frage ist,
Was sind jetzt eigentlich die politischen Gruppen, die jetzt hier an dieser Stelle diese doch relativ umfangreiche äh Planung dieser ganzen Subsysteme vorantreibt? Ist das eine Tätigkeit des,
Kommission ist es eine die Tiefkeit des Rates in irgendeiner Form, ist das Parlament eigentlich in irgendeiner Form
diese ganzen Aktivitäten mit eingebunden, gibt's da irgendeine Transparenz, also wo ist das angesiedelt? Weil Europa macht ja jetzt auch nichts aus sich heraus und nur weil die Innenminister der Meinung sind, das müsste alles so und so werden
wird's ja auch nicht gleich in so einem Betrieb umgesetzt.
Ja, das ist natürlich äh.
Das ist natürlich komplex, also bestimmt hat die Kommission da auch ein Eigenleben. Ähm das Parlament spielt meines Erachtens äh keine.
Muss ich leider so sagen, keine keine große Rolle, also das Parlament ist ja keine Firewall für Bürgerrechte äh
viele Sachen werden durchgewunken, also der der größte Battle an den ich mich erinnern kann war damals das Swift, das TFDP-Abkommen mit den USA
wo man dann nochmal so ein bisschen auf die Barrikaden gegangen ist hat aber nichts geholfen.
Ähm PNR wurde durchgewunken, aber viele dieser Änderungen über die wir jetzt hier gesprochen haben, erfordern ja gar keine Beteiligung des Parlaments, äh wenn so eine äh Verordnung äh beispielsweise erweitert wird.
Oder wenn äh der Zugriff anders geregelt wird oder wenn Europol jetzt die Möglichkeit hat, ähm äh Massendatenabgleich vorzunehmen. Das Problem haben wir ja auch in Deutschland, also dem Maizire sagt äh.
Ähm äh die Polizei muss äh das dürfen muss das können, was ihr rechtlich erlaubt ist,
Damit meint der Zugriff auf Verschlüsselung und äh Mustererkennung bei Videoüberwachung,
Guckt mal, aber in meinem Gesetz nach, im Bundespolizeigesetz steht. Ja, die Bundespolizei darf äh automatisierte äh ähm Kameras betreiben.
Aber da steht nichts von automatisierter Auswertung, da steht nichts von Algorithmen, die äh Gesichter abgleichen, äh runter Larmsch.
Kameras, die nach links nach rechts gucken.
Im Prinzip schon. Äh und viele dieser Regelungen äh ähm sind halt veraltet natürlich und halten halt quasi mit den technischen Entwicklungen die Schritt. Und so ähnlich würde ich das auch bei Europol sagen. Also dieses Ding mit ähm.
Das Europol äh diesen Massenabgleich von Daten äh vornehmen darf, äh das würde so in Deutschland nicht ohne Weiteres äh oder ich sage mal, das brauchte hier auch äh rechtliche Änderung
die Terrordatei ist das inzwischen möglich und in der äh Rechtsextremismus äh Datei ist das inzwischen möglich. Ähm.
Aber dem muss im Prinzip auch ein äh eine Gesetzgebung vorausgehen. Äh.
Das ist aber eh gerade ein Trend, oder? Ähm zu versuchen, alle Sachen ohne ohne Gesetzgeber zu machen. Also es kommt mir so der deutschen Innenpolitik gerade so vor. Ah, machen wir so eine Zities, diese Entschlüsselungszentralstelle
Parlamentsbeteiligung brauchen wir nicht, ja Cyber, Security, äh Cybersicherheit äh äh Richtlinie. Ja brauchen wir auch nicht. Also das das
alles irgendwie Bundeswehr im Innern, och das machen wir innerhalb des Grundgesetzes. Das ist irgendwie so ein Trend zu versuchen, das alles ohne ohne die,
ohne den Gesetzgeber ohne das Parlament eigentlich umzusetzen und zu sagen, das ist total egal, was wir machen, oder?
Äh du hattest die Frage war ja auch, äh welche Rolle spielt jetzt sozusagen, welcher Akteur auf Ebene der Euro.
Genau, also wer wer wer treibt das konkret voran? Ist es dann die ist das dann die Kommission?
Es ist unterschiedlich, also in diesen in diesen Datenbanken sind es im Prinzip die Mitgliedsstaaten, die das vorantreiben
also wo die Europäische Union dann so ein bisschen als Container benutzt wird
ähm dass äh einheitlich einzuführen, also man kann so ein bisschen beobachten, dass es da unterschiedliche, ich sag mal Zuständigkeiten gibt, also Deutschland ist äh.
Setzt sich sehr dafür ein, was sozusagen, also eben die Qualität der der Daten angeht, die Erhöhung des Datenaustausches, die Kompakt, also dass die Systeme kompatibel sind, äh untereinander,
und das wirklich der, also der Vorschlag, dass du Datenlieferungen an Europol regelrecht verpflichtend werden müssen,
Mitgliedsstaaten, die dem nicht nachkommen, werden dann irgendwie sanktioniert. Also solche Geschichten oder Datentöpfe, ähm, das ist so ein.
Sage ich mal so eine deutsche Spezialität, während Frankreich sich mehr über die,
Grenzgrenzüberwachung, Grenzkontrolle, äh, sage ich mal, kümmert, also viele Vorschläge in dem Bereich, äh, kommen aus Frankreich.
Wer in Großbritannien viel mehr äh so zu Radikalisierung, äh, Internetkontrolle, also auch diese Einheit bei Europol, zur Internetkontrolle ist nach britischem Vorbild errichtet worden,
beispielsweise, also kann man so ein bisschen entziffern, welche Mitgliedsstaaten treiben sozusagen, welche Sachen voran. Und da kommt jetzt wieder so ein Papier hier ins Spiel, wie das deutsch-französische, das ist äh diese sogenannten Non-Paper, äh sind auch ein bisschen Mode geworden.
Da tun sich dann einfach Regierungen zusammen äh und sagen jetzt mal sozusagen ihre Meinung. Ähm.
Und äh ja, hier kann man ja relativ äh gut sehen ähm also wie quasi sich jetzt eben Deutschland und Frankreich zusammentun,
Man kann sich übrigens auch fragen, hat das mit dem Brexit zu tun? Also, dass Großbritannien so ein bisschen als großer Player wegfällt und Deutschland und Frankreich sich äh
äh da quasi diesen Platz äh gerne ausfüllen, also ihre äh Macht in diesem Bereich Justiz und Inneres
noch zu verbreitern, weil viele andere Staaten sind da relativ bedeutungslos. Also Italien müsste man natürlich noch nennen, also Italien ist sehr wichtig für die ganze Zusammenarbeit mit den äh Balkanländern
also auch historisch, äh, was jetzt 'ne große Rolle spielt, äh, im Bereich de
sogenannten Sommers der Migration letztes Jahr ähm und so weiter, wieder die ganzen Balkanstaaten hergenommen werden zur Grenzüberwachung, also das ist sicherlich so ein äh,
italienisches Special, Polen, äh, äh, ist quasi in Osteuropa vielleicht noch 'n wichtiger Partner auch im Bereich Überwachung und,
Polizeisystematisierung aber im Wesentlichen sind da schon Deutschland und Frankreich die großen Motoren.
Aber wo müsste man jetzt sozusagen einen politischen Hebel ansetzen, wenn man Einfluss nehmen will auf diese ganze weitgehend sicher sozusagen von alleine abwickelnde entwickelnde äh Diskussion.
Also Bundestagswahl ist sicherlich nicht der richtige Ort über solche Sachen zu diskutieren und wenn das jetzt hier im Wesentlichen von der Kommission ausgeht, muss ja dann auch diese Kommission irgendwo ihre Ideen äh herbekommen und das kann ja dann am Ende wahrscheinlich nur der Rat der Europäischen Union sein.
Ja, die, da kommen die die Aufträge her, dass die Kommission dann eben quasi irgendwelche Vorschläge beispielsweise erarbeiten soll. Also inwiefern die ein Eigenleben haben.
Und dann vielleicht äh noch über den über das Ziel hinausschießen. Äh das kann ich jetzt so nicht beurteilen
Aber also im Wesentlichen äh sind es die Mitgliedsstaaten und dann ist so ein bisschen die Frage, wo setzt jetzt der Widerstand an äh
dagegen, also bei Vorratshattenspeicherung fand ich das eigentlich äh ganz interessant so zu beobachten, ne, wie das dann hier in Deutschland auch so verkauft wurde, als na ja, wir müssen das umsetzen, äh weil das kommt auch von der EU, wenn wir das nicht umsetzen ähm.
Dann gelang es aber doch in einigen Mitgliedsstaaten das vor den Gerichten anzufechten. Also was ist natürlich möglich,
aber dieser Erregungskorridor bei der Vorratssattenspeicherung, das kriegt man halt natürlich nicht hin, bei dem ganzen einzelnen äh Datenbanken, die dann als Richtlinien äh aufgesetzt werden, die dann umgesetzt werden müssen in den Mitgliedsstaaten. Ähm
Also das ja.
Weil ich meine, das erste einfach ein
unglaublich komplexes Thema und dann klingt halt hey die Datentöpfe so ein bisschen zusammen. Klingt halt auch erstmal nicht so schlimm und dann sind die alle viele Menschen unter diesem Eindruck von Terror eh zu sehr vielen Kompromissen bereit beziehungsweise heißen das gut. Man,
kann er generell.
Kochsendung, ne? Von von Melzer zu Messias.
Genau, die die Datenkochtopf sind, ne? Äh also das ist ja i gerade,
eine schwierige Situation für die für alle, die sich für Grund- und Freiheitsrechte und Datenschutz einsetzen, ist ja gerade also so eine.
Zumindest fühle ich so eine Art, das ist wie so ein Durchmarsch, der da gerade passiert. Und jetzt kommt wirklich alles rauf und es gibt äh relativ wenig Gegenwind und grade solche, also ich gerade so Datentopfgeschichten, also diese Datenbanken zusammenführen, was eine.
Absolut gefährliche Sache ist, datenschutzgemäßig kriegst du aber gar nicht auch erklärt quasi, ne? Also es ist sehr schwierig da irgendwie Leuten zu sagen, ja, aber das ist aber AITAS und EIC oder ich habe ja auch schon die ganzen,
Datenbanken haben nicht auf dem Schirm, ne? Also.
Bald heißt es nur noch Datentopf.
Viele ja viele viele Daten viele Datenköche wir verderben den Brei hier, ne.
Äh verderben die Demokratie vor allem äh.
Na, der Punkt ist ja auch, dass diese ganzen Sachen, die werden ja nie wieder zurückgenommen. Also die werden ja, wenn dann, wenn einmal eingerichtet wird, der Zweck erweitert. Ich kann mich jetzt wirklich nicht erinnern, wo es mal irgendwann äh überhaupt gefordert oder beziehungsweise dann durchgesetzt wurde
dass irgendeine Datenbank äh wieder eingedampft wurde beispielsweise. Also im Gegenteil
Und es gab dazu auch eine äh mal so ein Forschungsprojekt, wo Leute von Statewatch ist eine britische Bürgerrechtsorganisation, die sich seit fünfundzwanzig Jahren sehr hervortun in diesem Bereich. Also kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen, Statewatch äh Punkt org
die halt viel Analyse zu diesen Sachen auch machen und äh,
Die haben mal die nach nine Eleven äh auf den Weg gebracht, einen Antiterrormaßnahmen der EU äh sich angeschaut.
Kamen da auf die Zahl, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr genau, irgendwas äh an die dreihundert. Das war Stand von zweitausenddreizehn, also ich würde jetzt mal.
Ich glaube zweihundertsiebenundneunzig, also um die dreihundert äh Antiterrormaßnahmen äh bis zweitausenddreizehn. Ich wurde jetzt mal aus dem Bauch heraus sagen, äh
da sind mit Sicherheit äh fünfzig bis hundert noch dazu gekommen. Die Kernaussage dieses Projekts war aber
dass keine dieser Maßnahmen jemals evaluiert wurde. Also es wurde nirgendwo geschaut, welche war eigentlich erfolgreich.
Welche waren nicht erfolgreich? Und was bedeutet das, äh, wenn sie nicht erfolgreich war, dann heißt es doch nicht, äh, dass wir zusätzliche Maßnahmen machen, sondern dass wir die jetzt vielleicht erstmal wieder abschaffen
beispielsweise, aber diesen Prozess gibt es nicht. Also diese Bewegung gibt es auch nicht, also zu sagen
die Kompetenzerweiterung von Europol hat dazu geführt dass europäische Bürgerrechte durch den Massendatenabgleich ne erodiert werden meinetwegen schaffen wir wieder ab das wird es nicht geben.
Oder wir haben niemand gefangen. Also ich meine, das ist doch generell, glaube ich, auch so eine Sache,
irgendwie so evidenzbasierte Sicherheitspolitik, wenn man sich jetzt wirklich auf den Diskurs so einlässt, dann muss man das ja auf jeden Fall fordern, äh dass das wird ja nie der Nachweis gegeben, sondern es wird so ein bunter Strauß
wie auch wie diese Berliner Erklärung auch, ne? Das ist sondern man macht alles Mögliche auf von Videoüberwachung auf öffentlichen Plätzen bis Burka Verbot und mischt das alles munter zusammen, aber irgendwie Nachweis, dass diese und diese Maßnahme das und das bringen wird oder
nachhinein evaluiert, okay, wir haben das eingerichtet, dadurch haben wir das und das und das und das geschafft oder halt nicht geschafft. Das passiert halt generell nie. Das ist ja in diesem ganzen äh.
Sicherheitsdiskurs immer das Problem und es wird mittlerweile mit wir müssen, da möchten, dass subjektive Sicherheitsgefühl erhöhen, argumentiert auch, das war ja früher mal so eine,
bürgerrechtliche Kritik daran, hey, das ist ja nur das subjektive, jetzt wird es benutzt als Argument
Also ich finde das ist da muss man mehr ran, dass man dann sagt, hey ihr müsst doch effizient und evidenzbasiert eigentlich das machen und nicht äh so eine.
Ja und äh was auch überhaupt nicht absehbar ist, ist ja die Ausweitung äh sage ich mal der Zielgruppen dieser ganzen Maßnahmen. Also man sieht das wunderbare Europol. Diese Meldestelle für Internetinhalte
letztes Jahr im Juli wirklich im Schweinsgalopp, äh, wurde die umgesetzt. Im Juli zweitausendfünfzehn das erste Mal beschlossen wurde sie im April zweitausendfünfzehn, eingerichtet wurde sie im Juli
Es war überhaupt nicht möglich, das zu kontrollieren. Dann wurde gesagt, wir brauchen das wegen dem islamistischen Terrorismus.
Irgendwo im Subtext taucht er da mal auf äh ja und illegale Migration äh soll davon auch aufs Korn genommen werden. Ähm und äh,
Ja, nach einigen Monaten äh wurde das umgesetzt, dass dann eben auch ähm,
dass dann eben auch die Facebook Accounts von sogenannten Schleppern äh ähm offline genommen wurden. Jetzt erfahren wir
Gibt noch eine Erweiterung dieser Internet äh Meldestelle, hybride Bedrohung, also bei Netzpolitik wird das ja auch viel gecovert, hybride Bedrohung ist der Modebegriff
für das was die CIA seit Jahrzehnten in Lateinamerika macht, nämlich
verdeckte Kriegsführung, äh Unterstützung ähm von irgendwelchen bewaffneten Gruppen, um äh irgendwie
durcheinander Chaos zu kreieren und jetzt wird es eben quasi lediglich Russland angekleidet angekleidet und dieses ganze Phänomen hybride Bedrohung soll jetzt auch von dieser Meldestelle übernommen werden und was das dann bedeutet, also welche Internetinhalte dann später eben auch von Europol
zur Entfernung gemeldet äh werden, ist überhaupt nicht absehbar. Ich will damit sagen.
Dass das äh total beliebig ist und im Moment ist die Bedrohung, das äh gebe ich natürlich zu, äh, real von äh äh der Anschläge äh beispielsweise,
aber wenn es das mal nicht mehr ist, dann werden sich andere Gruppen finden, die dann quasi Ziel dieser Maßnahmen werden.
Generell ja so eine, sagen wir mal, äh aus bürgerrechtlicher Sicht irgendwie
immer das Ding, ne? Wo der, wie sagt man so schön, der wo ein Trug, da kommen die Schweine, das heißt, jedes System, was eingeführt wird, wird im Endeffekt
entweder ausgeweitet oder für andere Dinge genutzt werden. Ob das eine Datenbank ist, war früher mal für Kriminelle und am Ende kommt da jeder rein oder wir wollen ja nur die Leute, die von außen einreisen, also das ist ja sowas, was man immer beobachten kann.
Ähm und diese Meldestelle nochmal, das führt uns vielleicht auch nochmal zu diesem äh Diskurs hier im im Innern mit diesen Upload-Filtern
Ist das dann verknüpft oder was? Diese, also diese Meldestelle, wie geht die momentan vor? Die geben jetzt einen Inhalt.
Köpfungsvideo muss weg oder und dann, wie geht es dann weiter.
Also es ist ja so, dass die äh Internetanbieter sowieso nach ihren äh Richtlinien solche Sachen entfernen und normalerweise auch äh Meldungen kriegen von entweder Privaten, die im Netz irgendwas finden
oder eben selbst durch,
Vielleicht inzwischen automatisierte Verfahren äh äh nicht nur Brustwarzen finden, sondern vielleicht auch abgeschlagene Köpfe. Ähm und das dann äh quasi nach dieser Maßgabe auch entfernen.
Ähm das Neue an dieser Meldestelle ist eigentlich, dass äh eine Datenbank geführt wird ähm von bereits äh zur Entfernung gemeldeten Inhalten
oder von Inhalten, äh die dann tatsächlich auch gelöscht wurden
Das bedeutet, dass äh dass zum Beispiel die spanische Polizei sagt hier, wir haben hier so ein äh so ein so ein äh Video, das möchten wir bitte entfernt haben oder auch eine Audio äh Nachricht oder auch der Textdatei. Ähm und Europa kann er sagen,
haben wir schon, hat äh Deutschland schon vor drei Tagen zur Entfernung beantragt. Möglich ist aber auch, dass eure Pulland sagt,
Liebe spanische Polizei, äh die äh dänische, der dänische Geheimdienst hat darum gebeten diese Seite online zu behalten, weil sie sich wertvolle Informationen davon erhoffen.
Also wir möchten euch bitten sozusagen, dass die diese Seite nicht zur Entfernung zu wählen. Also Europol so eine Koordinationsfunktion hat. Damit fing es an. Ähm dann,
gab es ja seit Jahren eigentlich schon den den die Versuche Provider zur Zusammenarbeit mit der Polizei zu bewegen, auf europäischer Ebene, es hat nie richtig geklapp.
Und jetzt gibt's dieses äh Internetforum.
European Internetforum.
Genau. Und da spielt äh diese Mädelstelle bei Europol eine wichtige Rolle nach Selbstbezeichnung sogar die wichtigste.
Also wichtigster Akteur quasi um die Provider dazu zu bewegen, mitzuarbeiten,
Der Hintergrund ist der, dass Europol ja nicht den Datenstrom kontrollieren kann, also Europol hat äh keinen Zugriff, was aber YouTube äh hochgeladen wird, sondern kann erst Online-Gruppen, was es dann.
Vorhanden und.
Maßnahmen ergreifen. Und die Provider sollen jetzt eben Uploadfilter äh installieren, dass das Material erst gar nicht hochgeladen werden kann und die große Frage ist ja ähm wo wird diese Datei geführt.
Von da von Inhalten, äh die nicht mehr hochgeladen werden dürfen. Europol hat so 'ne Datei schon, die wurde vom BKA übrigens eingerichtet.
Check no bab heißt die. Und da sind all die Daten, äh, all die Audiodateien, Videos, äh, ähm, Textdateien gespeichert, ähm,
zur Entfernung beantragt wurden und die möglichst auch nicht mehr hochgeladen werden sollen. Das wird bedeuten, dass entweder YouTube, äh, Twitter, Facebook, wer auch immer,
auf diese Polizeidatenbank zugreifen soll mit dem Uploadfilter. Ähm oder das Europol seine Daten irgendeiner gemeinsamen,
Datenbank einverleibt, auf die die Privaten dann auch Zugriff haben werden. Das ist da habe ich noch keinen Vorschlag gesehen, wie das gemacht werden soll. Aber die Europolverordnung wurde schon mal geändert, Europol durfte bisher keine Daten mit privaten Tauschen.
Das dürfen sie jetzt.
Und ab Mai zweitausendsiebzehn ist das Europol gestattet.
Diese ganze komplexe was auch wieder interessant ist ja auch wieder Demonzier hat sich hier mit Facebook getroffen, da ging's auch um Uploadfilter
Ist auch wieder ein Prozess, in dem so eine Gesetzgebung eigentlich wieder umgangen wird, indem man so eine
öffentlich private Zusammenarbeit, Kooperation macht
Und quasi so eine freiwillige Kooperation und dann machen die Unternehmen mit und äh übernehmen quasi eine staatliche Aufgabe, ne? Also es ist so eine Privatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung.
Und sie sind ja auch unter Druck gewesen, ne, mit diesen ganzen äh Verfahren, die es gegeben hat. Es gab ja auch private Klagen äh ähm dass äh Facebook irgendwie Sachen runternehmen sollte et cetera und das ist so ein bisschen
ja das Ergebnis davon, dass die Privaten jetzt äh die Aufgaben der Polizei übernehmen sollen. Und.
Ich erinnere nochmal, angefangen von islamistischem Terrorismus, äh.
Nur mit Kinder pornografie hat's angefangen, oder? Diese Datenbank war do.
Der Uploadfilter, ja, das stimmt. Ähm hat mit äh Kinderpornografie angefangen, wo so ein Filter vielleicht auch noch äh leichter funktioniert, als bei äh irgendwelchen Propaganda-Videos ähm oder sowas.
Aber Ziel ist eben auch, dass äh äh auszuweiten auf andere Phänomene, so wie es bei der Meldestelle auch schon passiert ist.
Genau und da auch wieder das Problem, ne? Also das war am Anfang ist es Kinderpornografie, dann äh wird's islabistischer Terrorismus, dann wird Extremismus und dann wird sukzessive eben auf alle möglichen Phänomene, kann's ausgeweitet werden.
Ja und wer definiert das? Also wer definiert, ob ein äh ein Video an Propaganda-Videos oder nicht, also.
Willst gerne mal wiederholen. Ich finde diese Videos auch abscheulich. Ähm
aber ab wann ist ein äh ist eine Datei eine Meinungsäußerung oder bis wann? Und ab wann ist es eine Hassrede beispielsweise? Das ist ein totaler Graubereich.
Ja, der ist glaube ich eh gerade das Problem an der, diese ganzen Löschdiskussionen, dass eben nicht.
Irgendwie klar gesagt wird, okay, es geht hier dabei okay, das ist strafbar
Und da kann ich gegen vorgehen und dann löschen wir das, sondern es ist ja so ein schwammig, könnte zu Terrorismusgewinnung
und also also das ich glaub dass diese diese Uploadfilter ein wirklich großes Problem werden für die Meinungsfreiheit auch weil gleichzeitig wieder EU Deutschlands und Frankreichs Innenminister beide gefordert haben dass
Provider Privileg aufzuweichen. Hausproviderprivileg ist momentan so, wenn ich irgendwie eine Plattform oder einen Host äh bin.
Wenn mir zur Kenntnis gelangt, dass ein Inhalt illegal ist, dann muss den runternehmen. Und das wollen die quasi umkehren oder abschwächen, soweit, dass es äh.
Schon, dass ich dafür verantwortlich bin, was da drauf ist, als als Plattform.
Wenn ich das dann noch kombiniere mit Uploadfilter und dieser Angst von Privatwirtschaftlichen Unternehmen, oh Gott, ich könnte ja eigentlich eine Strafe bekommen. Dann wird das zu einer extrem überlöschung kommen, ne. Also das wird also das ist,
gefährlich äh diese Installation, diese Systeme. Man abgesehen davon weiß ich nicht, wie man das konnte. Also viele Sachen kommen ja auch in den Kontext,
Kann ein Hakenkreuz nehmen und kann über das Hakenkreuz schreiben als Symbol und wird das immer jetzt weggelöscht, aber ich kann das ja, also.
Und das schließt ja eh auch die Frage ein, warum sollte ich eigentlich nicht das Recht haben als Bürger äh.
Mir dieses Propagandavideos anzuschauen, um zu wissen, wie die ticken und was die machen. Also ich finde, ist ja ist ja eine Sache,
Hey, das ist ja mein Recht, ähm mich darüber zu informieren. Also diese Angst, dass das einmal die ganze Zeit Leute dazu bringt, dass sie sofort zu ISIS gehen und in sich in die Luft sprengen, halte ich halt auch für für Quatsch, ne? Also ich ich finde das schwierig, wenn.
Inhalte werden dann eben woanders erscheinen. Also dann wird es äh äh dann wird es ein Schengenbereinigtes Internet geben so ungefähr, also auf den Providern, die sich in Europa oder vielleicht in den USA, Kanada, Australien befinden
werden die Inhalte nicht verfügbar sein, aber in einem äh anderen Ländern schon.
Ja, es ist halt immer mal wieder so die das Ausweichen auf äh die Symptome, ne. So, hier Burkini.
Oh, da zeigt sich etwas, was wir an anderer Stelle verkackt haben und deswegen äh hauen wir ja einfach mal da drauf, ob er das bessere fällt uns jetzt gerade nicht ein. Ähm,
ja, ich würde das ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen jetzt zusammen äh fegen, das Thema war jetzt auf jeden Fall mal eine sehr interessante Einblick in diese gesamte Datenbank äh Welt kurz gesagt
erstens Systeme sind entstanden in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren, es kommen weitere kommen immer weitere äh Systeme dazu und es gibt einen ganz starken politischen Trend jetzt
dahin zu sagen, na ja, jetzt haben wir das doch alles schon, jetzt können wir das dann auch mal alles gemeinsam speichern, alles miteinander äh vernetzen und eben auch zu so einer,
umfassenden Bewegungsprofil und Strafverfolgungsdatenbank zusammenzurühren. Darum.
Geht's ja glaube ich vor allem immer mit dem Argument natürlich der Abwehr, der der Sicherheit und selbst wenn man das jetzt mal als äh legitim ansieht, dass natürlich ähm die Behörden
ob der Freizügigkeit innerhalb von Europa auch tatsächlich Probleme haben, legitime Strafverfolgung
effizient zu betreiben haben wir natürlich hier wieder diese klassische Reibung eben mit den mit der Freiheit der der Bewegung und der nicht über Wachbarkeit der der Bewegung,
mindestens der EU-Bürger, ja, über ähm Migranten und über äh Besucher auch Europas äh,
die betrifft es natürlich dann noch doppelt und dreifach und ja stellt sich natürlich jetzt die Frage, was man hier ähm.
Politisch für Einflüsse nehmen kann,
um diese Prozesse zumindest halbwegs äh im Griff behalten zu können. Wo siehst du denn da die besten Möglichkeiten? Matthias oder bist du schon vollkommen frustriert und siehst da d.
Ich hatte es ja vorhin schon äh äh mal kurz angerissen, also ich sehe da relativ wenig Möglichkeiten, also man kann natürlich versuchen, äh die eigenen Regierungen äh oder Gerichte irgendwie äh da zu bemühen, aber was äh Regierungen angeht, äh
kann man da ja wirklich äh die Hoffnung fahren lassen.
Und gegen diese einzelnen äh Geschichten zu klagen oder da weise äh einen nennenswerten Widerstand zu entwickeln,
sehe ich jetzt äh kaum und wenn dann werden die Richtlinien halt äh ein bisschen umgemodelt, aber kommen trotzdem.
Äh beispielsweise.
Ist in der EU-Gehalt in irgendeiner Form schon mal involviert gewesen und äh hat er sich schon mal in irgendeiner Form in irgendeiner dieser Datenbanken und in deren Zusammensetzung oder Betrieb auseinandergesetzt?
Da bin ich jetzt äh in dem Fall überfragt, also der Europäische Gerichtshof wird immer mal wieder bemüht, äh, wenn's um die
Umsetzung geht, aber nicht um die eigentliche Einrichtung ähm dieser Systeme.
Was ich halt auch ein ein Problem finde ist, dass es,
also es geht oder es ist ja so ein allgemeines Problem mit diesen ganzen äh Geschichten der Europäischen Union. Man weiß dann immer nicht, äh wo man ansetzen soll. Und wenn man äh wenn man sozusagen davon erfährt, ist es häufig schon zu spät. Also
bei der Vorratsseite Speicherung Geschichte war es ja auch so, dass die Bewegung ja eigentlich erst entstanden ist, als es darum ging, die schon beschlossene Richtlinie.
Umzusetzen in Deutschland. Aber eigentlich müsste man ja quasi aktiv werden, bevor solche Richtlinien beschlossen werden.
Aber das halt generell, glaube ich, ein Problem sozialer Bewegung, also Stuttgart einundzwanzig, Ude Bahnhof wird schon beim Abriss, die sind die meisten Leute da quasi, ne?
Union kommt halt dazu, dann auch ähm äh diese ganzen Sachen überhaupt erstmal zu scannen. Es gibt äh relativ wenig Gruppen, also im digitalen Bereich noch äh nochmal mehr, aber ich sage jetzt mal diese ganzen Datenbanksachen
das ist so 'ne Spezialität von wenigen
meine das haben nicht viele Leute verfolgt mit dem Passagierdatensystem. Da gab's ein paar Grüppchen, also Edris ganz sicherlich da ein wichtiger Player oder State Watch äh oder sowas
Aber Bewegung kann man das nicht nennen.
Dann ist auch die Frage, wenn wir jetzt so herkömmliche Protestformen meinetwegen machen wollen, wo demonstriert man denn dann, man kann ja nicht permanent nach Brüssel fahren mit so einem kleinen Häufchen. Ähm.
Wiesbaden zum BKA gegen die Interoperabilität. Nee.
Genau gegen den, gegen den großen Datentopf. Der warum eigentlich nicht.
Ja, aber ich finde, also ich glaube, das das klingt jetzt sehr sehr hoffnungslos und ich meine, es gibt ja auch Prozesse, die wo es richtig gezeigt hat, dass irgendwie auch ein komplexes Thema äh.
Beackert werden konnte, wie Netzneutralität, wo am Ende dann doch einigermaßen gut ist Ergebnis rauskam ähm
Also ich, das ist gerade schwierig. Ich glaube, dass die, dass sich diese äh Netzbewegung in einer Krise befindet
quasi und mehr mobilisieren muss, aber ich glaube, es gab doch immer wieder Hoffnungen und Punkte, wo man ansetzen kann.
Ja, aber dazu ist erstmal.
Das Problem ist halt einfach, dass wir noch sehr weit davon entfernt sind in irgendeiner Form eine nennenswerte europäische Öffentlichkeit zu haben
So, weil natürlich Sprache und auch kulturelle äh Unterschiede und auch teilweise einfach vollkommen unterschiedliche Sichtweisen darauf, was denn die EU ist und äh leisten kann, siehe jetzt äh Brexit in der Maximalausprägung
ähm auch mit so unterschiedlichen wirtschaftlichen Erfahrungen. Ich meine hier in Deutschland,
zu Wirtschaftlich gerade gar keine Diskussion um um die EU, warum auch und äh in Spanien sieht das natürlich dann wiederum äh ganz anders aus von Griechenland, will ich jetzt erstmal gar nicht reden.
Äh solche äh Luxusprobleme,
ja so First World Problems, die wir ja im Prinzip äh hier äh schieben, indem wir uns sozusagen über die Ausgestaltung bestimmter Regelungen bestimmter Datenbanken unterhalten und welche Flex da jetzt irgendwie drin sein sollten oder nicht, ja? Versus ganz anderer Probleme äh.
Kein Luxusproblem. Ich würde dann wieder sprechen, also ich meine, das geht ja um so ein Kern von von wie frei leben wir und das ist genau also also.
Überspitzt formuliert, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Also es ist einfach sehr schwierig da eine da eine wilde Debatte.
Es ist auch wenig greifb,
Ne, für die Leute, ne? Also kriegst das nicht mit, diese Daten, man, die ist da, die wird dann verknüpft und du gast jetzt selber, wenn kriegst du das gar nicht mit, aber dann der Pass durchgezogen, die sind alle zusammen, die Daten du im Zweifelsfall
hast du nicht dieses Betroffenheitsding. Ich glaube, das ist bei diesem ganzen Grund Bürgerrechte und Datenschutz. Äh das Problem, ne? Du kriegst irgendwie über
über diese Retargeting im Internet, ne? Ich guck mir irgendwas an
und kriegt auf einmal eine Werbung und die mich verfolgt, die Alukiste, die ich kaufen wollte über Wochen quasi, da merken Menschen, oh, da ist irgendwie Überwachung oder da ist irgendwie irgendwie wissen die, was ich da suche und so.
Das ist total real, aber so eine Datenbank, das ist, wie willst denn das zu einem Narrativ machen, dass das irgendwie scheiße ist und dich gefährdet letztlich.
Ja, es wird ja auch, es wird auch als Convenience angenommen, ne, weil man dann einfach nur noch so mit seinem Eriffaidie äh Pass einfach.
Durch, vielleicht nochmal so kurz ein bisschen drehen durch den Bodyscanner. Äh und dann macht's pling, grün, alles supi. Äh kriegst du ja gar nichts da mit dem äh noch nichts mal was davon mit, wie es in den anderen Schlammen zugeht.
Meine so ein bisschen Aufreger gibt's dann, wenn äh wenn man das mal so zuspitzt wie das Passagierdatensystem eben auch speichert, äh
eine Hotelzimmerbuchung und mit wem du das Hotelzimmer äh gebucht hast, äh, beispielsweise. Ähm, also bei solche Sachen äh.
Ein bisschen das überhaupt nochmal verständlich zu machen, was es bedeutet, aber ja auch das Passagierdatensystem wurde beschlossen.
Ja Freunde, ich denke.
Liest Netzpolitik liest Sadewatch.
Das ohnehin, genau, wir haben.
Nicht auf, gib nicht auf. Immer.
Zahlreiche
äh zahlreiche äh äh Links heute in den Shownotes. Äh wir haben ganz viel Wikipedia ausgegraben zu all den äh Begriffen teilweise gibt's noch nicht mal Wikipedia Artikel dazu. Also nichts wahrzufinden zur EU Lisa. Äh nicht zu geplanten Systemen. Also an der Stelle äh kann man eine allein die
dokumentatorische äh Pflicht der Gemeinde vielleicht auch nochmal anmahnen, äh sozusagen auch Proposels und geplante äh Systeme hier frühzeitig zu dokumentieren. Das würde ja schon mal helfen.
Das zumindest schon mal nachschlagen kann.
Es gibt auch im äh September wieder ein Freedom Not vier Aktionchen in Brüssel. Wobei ich jetzt leider vergessen habe, wann.
Im September. Äh Aktionchen im Sinne von.
In Brüssel treffen von Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten auf die Straße gehen. Also das hat in den letzten Jahren gegeben, mehrtägig.
Waren nicht viele, aber ich glaube qualitymäßig sind das auf jeden Fall äh äh interessante Veranstaltungen.
Ich schaue gerade, ich glaube wir reden vom Oktober, vierzehnter bis siebzehnter.
Das Meeting, das meinst du, ne? Anyon Meeting for Sivers, Activist from Audicross, Europe, das vierzehnter bis siebzehnter Oktober in Brüssel lege ich auch noch drauf.
Ja, dann vielen Dank, Markus, vielen Dank, Matthias.
Und äh damit machen wir dann hier den Datentopf auch erstmal zu.
Tim Melzer.
Genau und äh sagen äh
Erstmal tschüss und ich warne euch schon mal vor, da kommt jetzt auch nochmal schnell zu einem anderen schönen Thema, nochmal eine kleine Sendung hinterher, damit wir hier diese ganze äh Medienlage auch äh gut abgegriffen bekommen. Selbst wenn äh die Nuss mal wieder flüchtig ist.
Und ich habe gehört, da gibt's sogar was positives zu vermelden nach dem ganzen traurigen Dingen.
Genau. Könnt ihr euch schon mal drauf freuen. Ich sage tschüss. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Tschüs.